a podcast
unless you guys are talking about your
stock portfolio
talking about diversification how it's
important
welcome back to this episode of trash
taste i'm connor and of course i'm
normally with the boys and joey and
today special guest michael oh
you're barely here
[Laughter]
you're looking so deep you look like a
lost child right now i am i am i am well
you know i'm sure many of you know who
michael is but you know you have to do
the generic oh you are you introduce
yourself for people
who don't know who you are yeah robotics
on youtube
yeah
that's that's really is that how you
would describe what you do what i tell
people yeah
yeah i don't know it's hard to say what
what it is really it's like i usually
just say robotics yeah okay yeah like a
crack crackhead engineer yeah pretty
accurate i'd say yeah yeah similar
engineer
the energy you give off in your videos
is that of you know yeah like if mark
over went down the wrong path
that's awesome so do you tell people
you're engineers or just work in
robotics i just say i work in robotics
okay sometimes i'll just say software
developer like like what do you say you
know like when you get in an uber you
don't explain your whole life because
like in japan uber drivers rarely talk
to you oh really yeah yeah we don't even
have uber yeah oh yeah that's true yeah
no they do no they do they do but like
it's like we have our own version of
uber though yeah yeah we do we do yeah
but yeah no they never talk they're just
like are you having a nice day and
you're like yep and they're like okay
let's get the temperature
because like i'd see the memes about oh
like the uber drivers that would like
not talk to you and you give them five
stars and like in most places i go to
taxi drivers don't really talk to you at
least in the uk like if you take a black
cab they're more likely to talk to you
but if you take a new button nobody
[ __ ] talks i haven't had a single
uber since i got to la that has talked
to me that's crazy yeah they all talk to
me really yeah because that's that's
what i hear it's like the stereotype
right like they love like starting
conversation getting to know you on the
ride yeah usually like if i don't know
maybe i just give off the aura of like
don't [ __ ] talk to me yeah the moment
i get in they're just like joey all
right
and then they just don't converse it is
weird how that like this the sat nav
that always keeps going like drop conor
off into and i'm like oh it's weird it's
singing
we're gonna die
yeah i think on the app sometimes it
makes like the driver's profile it'll be
like excellent conversationalist and
every time i say that i'm like [ __ ]
they're going to talk to me
i ain't going to be able to say [ __ ]
oh because everyone's ready to use a
good tool yeah yeah yeah there's like it
actually has like a little picture like
speech 100. you know i had this uh one
guy who was a took us to lax and he is a
real estate agent he picked us up in a
[ __ ] like tesla fully tricked out
okay he came up to us and he's like yeah
i do this just to get clients because
he'll only patrol rich ass places right
and he'll like just get clients i'll be
like yep i am a that's so [ __ ] yeah
it was genius yeah it's so genius what
the [ __ ] that was awesome yeah i gotta
give you props by the way because me and
connor are both technically engineers
but you've somehow found a way to be a
content creator but still make use of
engineering yeah we still make use of
your engineering degree right now
engineering degree yeah really yeah
that's where we're like opposites i i
don't have an engineering degree
no no i don't you serious yeah you went
to university though no i went well i
went to one year of university and then
dropped out because that's all right it
was yeah well i i've always said this
but enjoying an engineering course makes
you realize that you don't want to be an
engineer
because it's just boring it sucks
something especially at like university
type thing yeah
everybody thinks are you going to be in
the lab all the time doing stuff you i
was in front of a pc math yeah doing
math lab and simulations for just hours
it's like an engineering software that
specializes in like maths and equations
programming language pretending to be
like a really actually useful
programming yeah no one uses it for
anything yeah yeah the problem is like
like usually you should be taught stuff
that you will use outside but it's not
useful outside of the degree so you
think that in the degree oh it will help
me learn faster no it makes you learn
slower and shittier it's like it's it
has zero how do they use it
it's just what they've always said yeah
why do schools do a lot of the things
absolutely that's true
so like i guess like that that's really
interesting so
you don't have your energy your
engineering degree so did you make your
content to make engineering fun
because i i feel like you were one of
the first is like you know to us
engineering engineering was always
boring but you're watching your videos
you've somehow made the process of
engineering look [ __ ] fun it was like
really boring like i did have like a
real job in it yeah and doing software
development for like these uh the state
of hawaii and that was very boring
and i learned it in like a very fun way
and then that made it boring so i wanted
to do like fun projects yeah like make
it better so i actually had like a bunch
of [ __ ] that i made before doing youtube
and i made something and i was like oh
this would be funny to put on youtube
and then yeah that's how that happened
yeah so it was kind of like to make it
more fun for myself right because that
passion was [ __ ] dying quickly at the
job yeah instantly man if you've
probably if you finish the degree you
probably wouldn't be doing this right
now
[ __ ] no man it just felt like it was
never applicable to anything like they
were making us apply for jobs and i was
applying for this job and they were in
the interviews they were asking me
questions i was just like am i supposed
to know this [ __ ]
like what
oh i mean so obviously they would have
asked you to explain like engineering
concepts and stuff yeah the times would
ask you to explain something you're like
i don't even like know what that is
and then i look like a [ __ ] clown
yeah i've had my fair share of clown
interviews you drive like two hours you
wait you you wear a suit that you don't
really know what the [ __ ] you're doing
with you get there and just some old man
grills you and you feel like you're
humiliated yeah yeah what uh what are
your
parts of engine mechanical both i did
mechanical he did like electronic and
electrical engineering yeah i mean like
i get the interview thing uh i draw i
drew a dick in one of my interviews uh
because i applied for a music missile i
applied for a missile company and i
ended up uh on a like unknowingly
drawing a dick and i didn't realize
until the end of the interview of course
i didn't get it
uh and then elon musk stole your design
did you so i guess like did you quit
your engineering degree for youtube i
mean after oh no um
i didn't even get far into the
engineering degree like it was just one
year um it was like a python
introductory course right and
so i like was
i like went to college for engineering
but i had to pay for it like with my job
that was already doing engineering yeah
and it was like this that doesn't make
any sense yeah i'm learning to pay you
yeah i paid to learn so i can work in it
and it's like i already got the job yeah
and the class like was you know it's
like an intro thing they wouldn't let
you do any kind of like testing out of
it or anything right so it's like this
is a variable that's good
um so it just like it also sucked having
to do like a bunch of classes that had
nothing to do with it that isn't yeah so
yeah i feel like they have to fluff it
out they're like yeah yeah you need to
learn how you know the project like the
like line will work and it's like well i
mean i mean like i guess yeah even
before that like having to take like an
english basic english word they did that
yeah yeah cause it's like uh it was oh
yeah right you guys went in the uk right
yes yeah yeah yeah uk it's all done
three years yeah yeah oh yeah so it's
all pretty like yeah like pretty like
full-on i hear it's like turbo fluff
yeah if you're not going to an
engineering specific school right um so
like a general education school that i
went to the worst school ever northern
arizona university [ __ ] you northern
um i pissed on that sign when i went
back through there
with my dog uh
yeah it was uh so you i i was in like a
like
ancient chinese history and i was like
this doesn't
sense degree in an engineering degree
this in make
they make you take liberal studies as
well yeah i know you're paying to do
engineering yeah yeah because like you
need those to get into the higher level
engineering degrees
like the classes it's [ __ ] stupid
it's crazy yeah it's actually insane
what does anyone study in america
they can go to good schools and stuff i
went to a like a pretty the reason i
went to this one was because they had
like a 90 acceptance rate i had some bad
grades in high school right fair enough
yeah but i mean you know the whole
grades equal intelligence thing is all
kind of weird anyway and yeah yeah
arbitrary but there's you know who's
going to make a better system yeah so
you mostly mostly like self-taught now
with some yeah mostly for like
for soft yeah for all of yeah mostly
self-doubt well you heard of engineers
you don't need an engineering degree
anymore to do engineering right
google
youtube yeah honestly that's like google
and youtube tutorials just like that
that taught me more in my engineering
degree than my [ __ ] lectures
like yeah i'm not gonna [ __ ] laugh
like the indian people on like khan
academy making dude if they don't have
an accent you're not learning good
for real it's a bad tutorial
those [ __ ] have put up like
five hour tutorials too for free it's
like holy [ __ ] and it's all like
consistent it's all yeah yeah it's
always there's no fluff no [ __ ] they
get right to the point i don't know how
they learn to teach so well yeah but
they do they do
i just think that like the the
universities they're like hey you need
to fill this many hours so just make
[ __ ] up yeah just like
just just start dragging stuff out i had
one guy and um
he
i think this guy because obviously the
teachers they also get graded on how
good they're teaching right yeah yeah so
it was a notoriously hard module it was
just dynamics yeah which is just like
anything i guess yeah and a lot of
people failed the year before so they
brought a new teacher and this guy
clearly just did not give a [ __ ] he was
just there for the paycheck because at
the end of the course he's like come to
my revision lessons yeah you better come
to it you're not going to want to miss
it
and so we were like all right
yeah it was like all right okay cool so
we go up and he literally just just goes
through the exam that's coming up in a
week but just with different questions
just different numbers right he just
goes through it in order yeah oh my god
and so the first time that happened
you know maybe some people turned up the
second time he did it everyone showed up
yeah yeah because they knew it was
happening it's literally just a cheat
sheet yeah it was [ __ ] that's great it
was fun
you got some professors that are like
because like that are obviously there
for like the research side of the new
university they're working on different
projects yeah because they cannot
lecture for [ __ ] yeah
it's kind of like they only do it
because it's like a contractual
obligation yeah you know i'm researching
some cool projects but you've also got
to lecture some students and you can
always tell because they like speak from
like a different [ __ ] dimension you
know they they it's they talk to you
like you're already like a professor
great level yeah like level of knowledge
yeah so it's it's like a really like
like you're not conversing with a human
no no no
so it's like really hard to find good
professors because it's hard to get one
that does both yeah who like knows what
they're talking about and there's a good
teacher yeah cause like some of the
smartest professors you meet just aren't
they are [ __ ] teachers those are the
worst teachers right yeah yeah yeah for
sure different skill set man i gotta ask
though what is your creative process
behind how you like make your videos how
did you get like your video ideas from
man because you have like some of the
craziest [ __ ] video ideas i think on
the platform yeah i don't know just it
happens
like it happens very rarely so it's like
probably the most annoying [ __ ] is like
with an idea that i think is good yeah
that i like would have fun doing yeah um
that's probably why it takes so long to
make videos yeah i don't know i just
like will be doing something and i'd be
like this i could make this way more
complicated and stupid do you have like
a short list of ideas of like things you
like might want to pursue yeah i got a
couple of them i got yeah i had a yeah i
do have a short list of ideas but a lot
of them are like maybes i think one is
like yeah a lot of them are like
dependent on if it will work i think one
is like a meat roomba a roomba made of
meat
[Music]
and i had like a baby killing drone idea
but that one
i
i didn't end up doing that do you want
to expand upon that yeah
um it's like a drone yeah that would
like uh it would kill babies like lego
pieces like choking hazard like no
oh oh pneumatic spike on the drone and
it would find it the idea was to
they need that
have you ever had like an idea that
you've started working on because like
it takes you like [ __ ] months to do
it so i can't imagine being in your
position where you have to like commit
to one idea and you like need to commit
to this for months yeah i try to
validate it as fast as i can because if
it doesn't if it isn't good then i'll
like you know shoot it and just not do
it
i'll kill it uh because it's just not
available so i like try to get
like um like in the beginning i'll like
try to get as much done on like the tech
side of stuff just like validate like
okay this is gonna work to the end of
the video and then i'll like start the
video and it'll be like halfway done
i'll do it like in the middle and stuff
but i get to a point where i'm like okay
the video will work because i don't want
to start filming and then i'm like this
isn't gonna work yeah yeah what like
percentage of ideas do you scrap would
you say um i don't know
usually i'm pretty good at not
trying pursuing saying this yeah yeah
yeah i'm good at like killing it before
i even like try to do it yeah usually
yeah um yeah so i just shoot down like
90 percent of like what's the
what's the video that took you the
longest from like start to finish oh
um
the like longest in time yeah probably
like the the that the
uh like a the beard pissing dog video i
made
that took a pretty long that or the um
the surgery robot was really intense
yeah yeah crazy um i spent a lot of time
like i had a really good time working on
that was one of my favorite ones yeah
because it was like good work every day
like i would always like make some
progress yeah i'd wake up and i'd be
like okay these 3d printed parts don't
fit together so good i'll print it out
tomorrow and i wake up they get down off
the printer and then like sit in my
garage listen to music and like the door
would be open yeah and i'd like have
everything working and that one went
pretty well yeah it just took a really
long time to like get everything down
for that right yeah that was a great one
i i really like sounds like tony stark
or something like that
so like that that thing wasn't small
what are you doing with all this stuff
oh so that dude i uh well that one i
used a little bit for stream so
i i i like attached a camera to it and
um to where the knife was yeah and i
used like a instead of the hand thing
it's like
controller yeah i never just moved
around so people could see what i was
doing on the table when i was streaming
um but then when i moved i was just like
i i like cut it up and took all the
electronics and all the good bits and
just threw the rest away yeah yeah that
one was way
[ __ ] in like a storeroom somewhere i
imagine if it's like practical you're
like i can keep the roomba yeah yeah
yeah it's small too it's like an easy
kind of yeah have you ever come close to
like injuring yourself because like i
see some of your [ __ ] inventions i'm
like this is a couple times usually
electrocution is like the main concern
that's just a normal thing right a lot i
mean i've never heard i like taste or
anything it's been a while since oh
really no i shouldn't say that should i
why did you like perk up it's not as bad
i think everyone should know at least
it doesn't look that bad because
everyone seems okay after it yeah i mean
it's really weird because it's like it
hurts really bad but it's not like
getting hit where it hurts for a while
because it hurts really bad and then not
at all
[Applause]
neither of us have been tased so yeah
yeah
and there's a difference between like
stun gun tasers like that you get on
amazon and like you always take a
difference yeah like a police taser's
like you probably shouldn't do that yeah
i'm not gagging over it
i'm like
i'm good
if i don't but did you ever watch what's
uh was it coyote peter
well when i was a kid i did get the
mains of my house across the chest
through the heart wow um okay so i like
i wasn't super
good at any that at that stuff
but i knew
electricity you've been [ __ ] with
like
a kid like well not like like since i
was like maybe 14 like vaguely because
we had a lot of trash around our house
yeah super villain all superhero artists
like i would just like get a bunch of
batteries and stick them together and
the wires would heat up and be like
that's sweet and then i was like dude we
have electricity in the walls
why am i messing with batteries and so
you gotta pay for jerusalem
for that [ __ ] i would just cut uh like
like a cord a power cord and just cut it
and then get the two wires and i would
just flick them together and in like
stranded wires
instantly like uh especially if it's
like thin stranded
in a bunch of sparks and molten copper
everywhere and it's really cool and so i
was like [ __ ] the the copper is like
getting all messed up so i soldered like
or not solder i probably just twisted
the wire and hot glue yeah that was my
soldering forever yeah was twisting the
wire on metal and hot gluing no yeah
dude like even into many youtube videos
so i twisted that and i was like
tapping that and i don't know i just
touched the boat and then like got the
got through the chat i [ __ ] you up like
no i mean well you don't do it yeah
yeah yeah cause you would not recommend
this yeah and you would you would super
die in the in super giant
in japan 140 voltage oh yeah
no wait no wait uh it's 220 right yeah
yeah 220 see it's 240 in the uk right
yeah
even better and so that's
yeah yeah [ __ ] i get scared watching
um electro booms videos yeah
yeah he just always trips wise and stuff
i know he knows what he's doing i think
i don't know he seems like he knows i
think yeah i don't know but he did one
video where he went to the uk yeah and
he was in a hotel room yeah and uh he
just he tries to like short the the
mountains and he just [ __ ] the whole
wall is black
like the whole thing yeah he's like oh
this this mains in the hotel is not that
good in the uk i'm like what the [ __ ]
can you just go to a hotel and do that
dude he did it in hawaii too
i know he does it i know why he does it
he goes and does it so he can tax right
off the vacation for his family
yeah yeah so this is like a kind of
thing i think i assume he's an engineer
i really agree with him
yeah he's very knowledgeable yeah i
think i've seen some of his videos he
actually shocks himself quite often
literally
i think usually it's control i think the
one that was scary was his jacob's
ladder video for like a million oh that
was [ __ ] scary yeah because that
one's like like with 220 or like maine's
in a house it's like you you you
probably won't die but like obviously
there's a chance you will yeah but
there's like it's not guaranteed but
like the jacob's ladder it's like 16 000
volts it's like instant death yeah you
touched it yeah through the chest and
his he was like celebrating some
subscriber milestone is going up and
like he kicked the wire and it fell
towards him yeah i saw that i don't know
how he like managed to get out of the
way because that [ __ ] has to be instant
death yeah yeah
i just can't believe how reckless he is
you should watch it it's very yeah
just don't understand people who are
okay around livewire well i mean if
you're if you've probably studied it
your whole life you probably feel a bit
more comfortable probably not a good
idea still but yeah you know i can
understand why he'd be like i know
exactly how all this works yeah i've got
that
[Music]
well yeah but then the [ __ ] annoying
ones that we should we got like the
three-pronged ones which is just like
it's so much bigger than any other
plunger it's huge it's [ __ ] massive
right but but every plug has a fuse in
it yeah like and you can change it yeah
it's really nice it's quite smart yeah
you don't have to worry about it so is
that where your obsession with getting
electrocuted started at a young age
or electrocuting other people you want
to like you want them to experience what
you're experiencing insane i don't know
were you that kid that stuck the fork in
the socket
you're the reason why we have those like
things on the uh
yeah
please don't electrify the legos they do
not survive
all right not gonna do that yeah but
damn i mean we have to talk about it
boxing yeah oh yeah
i'm sure you've talked about this to no
end actually not that much surprisingly
not that much let's go let's bring it
off
let's go i mean how how was that how was
that whole process it was so awesome uh
i will never do it again
yeah because like like i i love
everything i actually really loved
everything about it except for like
realizing like i feel my [ __ ] brain
moving when i get hit and i don't like
that
like being dizzy the day afterwards yeah
like a hard sparring is not it but like
everything like the training is cool
because you're working towards a goal
especially with create a clash you know
you're doing a thing
to get in shape
exactly yeah i had the trainer comp i
had like the best trainer possible he
was great um he was like a golden gloves
champ in the state of california and
like almost the nation i think he
probably was uh goddamn yeah and so it's
like awesome but i won't do it again how
intense was like the training leading up
to us it was pretty intense like how
long did you have to do it for um so i
didn't have i i got in like near the end
of when they're getting people so i had
not as much time but i did it
um
i think generally it's you should do it
a lot it's like for me it was five times
a week um and then every day was like a
run before my coach got there he'd come
yeah and then we'd do like
jump rope some like pads um like he hit
the bag some ladders yeah some just a
whole bunch of [ __ ] right and then
it was done so all in all it was like a
good like two
some hours three some hours every day
there's a lot of times yeah yeah it was
um it was good yeah we got like a lot of
sparring into as far as like the most
important part because you get to
actually see what
it's like it's like everything you've
learned up until then is gonna be like
soul all the time right
after sparring a little bit
um generally after like doing the
training itself for a while yeah you're
going to warm up for it yeah um but it
was very intense it was quite
interesting so how many like months were
you doing the five days a week um i want
to say like uh like three to four months
but it like there were like times when i
had to go somewhere on vacation not on
vacation but like go to another place
for like two weeks at a time and i had
to stop or like find a treadmill there
and just run right right right yeah yeah
[ __ ] it was the [ __ ] on the train yeah
yeah i think no one thought it was going
to be super intense or like if we were
like okay youtuber boxing whatever but
then like we saw how serious uh ian like
idubbbz is yeah yeah and he'd come over
like to every city that fighters were in
right and he'd be like make sure we have
a coach everything we'd like meet his
coach and he's like yeah i'm training
five times a week i all i do is [ __ ]
eat chicken and rice and this is all i
do i breathe boxing and i was like holy
[ __ ] you're taking it really seriously
did you like adapt your diet as well to
be like the i like to diet yeah i tried
to just eat like generally okay nothing
intense yeah yeah just as much like
chicken and rice as i could right like
you know i'd sneak some
meat in there like some steaks and stuff
yeah that was fun chicken meat yeah yeah
yeah
so how was the event itself because i
think that was awesome yeah because
we're just talking to lily about how
nervous she was just watching you get on
stage you're getting like
tough yeah it was awesome though like
the place was filled out yeah um
the crowd was amazing they were just
like yelling non-stop freaking the [ __ ]
out yeah yeah it was just like it's such
a well put together event everyone looks
awesome yeah yeah so [ __ ] good i
can't like describe how it was walking
out it was amazing yeah what was going
through your mind when you were because
that must have been like holy [ __ ] this
is actually going to happen i'm actually
like it was kind of like mentally numb
at that point yeah i heard uh [ __ ] my
song come on is mine diamonds yeah yeah
i love that parody yeah yeah and that
made everything better yeah
all the world is right when you were
when you were walking in the rain were
you like i think i've got this like i
think um
you're good friends with that with
graham yeah yeah yeah we are um i
was feeling actually nervous up until
like we started and even when we were
going i
the first time was shaky for you yeah
yeah i was very unsure because like my
plan was to just gauge first the coach's
plan you know you gauge first round get
them a little tired like play kind of
defensively and then in the second round
you can move off of that that's what i
was trying to do as much as i can right
but like
even following that plan i was like [ __ ]
he's kind of like hitting
i know he's getting me
i know this is the plan but i'm
still scared yeah i think there was a
moment where i was like i need to start
hitting him
and in order to win or i will lose yeah
yeah because obviously the points right
technical yeah yeah and i felt like i
was losing like the entire first round
but i think it went even um
yeah it was complete like it was crazy
seeing it from the outside because it
felt
weird completely like this yeah like how
much of what how much you remember being
in the ring do you remember like people
chanting your names because i do
remember that okay like i was like
that's nice that that's nice
shut the [ __ ] up
that did help out it was nice i was like
oh man these people are going to see me
goddamn lose
yeah it was amazing it was really cool
um yeah but it did like kind of shut out
everything else right you're supposed to
listen to your coach like they're
supposed to be calling [ __ ] and it's
like he could have been speaking
different languages
he's
you're supposed to like your coach is
supposed to be like hey [ __ ] take it
downstairs jab get back on the jab and
like i'm listening to none of that
is that like an amateur thing or is that
like you just when you're like for every
box i think ever at every level you're
able to do that and i think it's a pro
level date because then they get to what
they actually get to see from the
outside and they'll be like okay it will
work if you go downstairs and hit the
body or whatever right yeah and so i
listened to him a little between the
rounds
a little bit yeah a little bit yeah did
you want some water yeah all right sure
yeah yeah it was uh it was super fun um
i my coach was training like three of
the people who were fighting so he was
busy as hell oh okay um
i and it was really official backstage
backstage was nerve-wracking because we
get there and there's like the blue
locker room and the red locker room uh
yeah that's what we're split up by like
the people who are fighting wow
uh not a lot of people know but before
the fight there was a pro fight in that
same arena just not streamed right and
the pro so there was one pro in our room
and one pro in their room and our pro
got tko'd first round of his fight and
he so he came back to the locker room
and he was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and everyone's just
like this giant
huge professional boxer pissed as [ __ ]
and so we're like all like nervous as
hell oh my god yeah really bad vibes in
our the other one
i heard after they were like yeah let's
go and then he goes out to the [ __ ]
minecraft turn their [ __ ] off
i'm gonna cry yeah
yeah and then we had matt matt in our
room we saw him get just annihilated
we didn't get to see anything live until
after our fight so we're like in there
watching the tv and we watched the first
round like jaws hanging open like what
the [ __ ] is that how all of them are
we didn't know we were like yeah is this
what was happening what have we gone
ourselves into i'm gonna do that that's
gonna happen to me i was so nervous i
was just like sitting there not talking
to anyone will got some really good
footage of me just like sitting there
with headphones in just like listening
to music as much as i could so like how
how does like it compare to like when
you went sparring because like was it
something where kind of like your
experience just took over you know with
all the sparks i had to like try and be
kind of conscious about it i had to
consciously think like i will be making
these moves but like sparring it was
crazy too because in sparring i did like
like five six seven sparring sessions
with different people i never won like a
single round of sparring and you're not
supposed to you know you know you're not
winning in sparring right now it's not
counted who are you sparring against my
head [ __ ] hurts after i lost that
round you know right um yeah uh so i
sparred against my coat first and he's
like you know a
professional and so he has to like hold
back so you're not fighting someone
really you're finding a good guy who's
holding back it's like when you like
hold back and smash against your
girlfriend
no reaction she's right there
yeah and so i
bought him he shits on me constantly
obviously yeah um we went to another a
gym right uh and they were very nice
they were trying to find viewers bar and
there was this girl who's like
professional she's i was scared as [ __ ]
of her um i was like how long have you
been sparring she's like since i was
like nine and i was like okay that seems
fine and kick the [ __ ] out of you do she
that was the hardest i've been punched
she had the heart she hit me the hardest
out of anyone else
it was cool to see different techniques
because my coach is very like fluid and
all over the place yeah she had like
incredible defense she'd like block
everything and frustrate the [ __ ] out of
you i need to come in and she'd like
have this really good check hook and she
just blast your head yeah yeah and like
getting hooked like that that was i even
felt the dizziest on that day yeah so
yeah how many times a week are you
sparring it's like every single time
no um in the beginning you need to like
get up to snuff and then
and then when like my coach thought i
was ready um
once or twice a week yeah uh it's gonna
be scary though once twice a week yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you're getting your all speed yeah yeah
and the the the second one is like
contingent on how much you heard from
the first one oh my gosh um yeah so i
got crushed by her i got beat up by a 14
year old child i i believe i saw some of
the kids
he was really good i'm not even
embarrassed about that yeah he's really
good um he's like a national champion
for his age okay he's like the
he best really great he looks like aang
from avatar where he was like floating
around the ring
he was like moving just so much and like
and then get out and then he's like i
can't hit him
you know you know i've seen like every
anime where there's like a tournament
like in huntante and then you see the
kid come on you realize that you're the
[ __ ] side character
teleports behind you
have you ever watched hajime no ippo um
i got clips from africa after the boxing
people were talking about it yeah
because i i think you did like one of
the i guess move similar to what they do
yeah
yeah you know dempsey's a real guy yeah
yeah that's crazy it's just he just he
just took the move and kind of made it
like a more popular thing in the show
right yeah so normies know it but yeah
everyone knew it like yeah it's real
he's like one of the best right he was
very good yeah yeah damn he had like a
mike tyson style thing where he was like
and then yeah exactly i mean that's
that's what like the main character
channels anime without knowing it
yeah
power of golden anime uh it's like a
like a very good defense you're supposed
to shift against a hook right that's
when you're supposed to do the role yeah
yeah
but most of that [ __ ] goes out the
window yeah yeah yeah
i tried a boxing class like a few days
ago oh i saw it that was my coach you
know him yeah he was crazy like he was
so fast michael right yeah yeah yeah
when he was doing like he said no you
got to do it like this i'm like what did
you just do i couldn't even see what
he's so smooth
okay
all right okay
he's like one of those anime characters
where he punches once and he's like
actually punched three times
but like four days afterwards my entire
body hurts yeah and dude like you can't
use your phone your hands yeah yeah your
fingers are [ __ ] cute
we're like rubber he's like i couldn't
walk jesus i felt like i i look like an
idiot when i was walking full-time
commitment luckily i'm in america
yeah it was dude it was just like every
workout was a sprint yeah like i i
thought i was pretty fit because i do a
lot of running yeah running it was did
not prepare me for this yeah it's like
you have to do sprint training yeah it's
like a full-on cardio workout it's full
on like basically sprinting every
exercise yeah yeah yeah yeah no it
really is like uh when you're like doing
the treadmill you're supposed to like
run in sprints instead of just
constantly yeah yeah yeah cause it's
like you're trying to imitate the rounds
yeah yeah it was [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up don't look like a cool class
though it looks sweet yeah it was kind
of cool i mean i think it was like
pretty big so it's hard to really feel
like you were learning anything like
yeah yeah tailored to you but i mean
it's good though it was only like one
class so you know yes there's more room
could you do that five days a week for
months at a time
okay i think i would like what i was
saying is like i think i would enjoy it
more if i was like just me and him and
then i could take my time and then right
you could really give me like all right
you're struggling here yeah yeah so just
be like all right 12 of you do jabs and
then you would maybe be like yeah it's
okay
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
am i actually doing it right i don't
know
but yeah no i i mean it seems i really
want to do it yeah it seems fun it looks
really fun but also
it looks terrifying at the same time was
there a point when you knew that you had
this because i like i i can't remember
which round it was but like it really
looked like you were feeling yourself
yeah there was a point where like i like
one punch yeah i was like that really
hit his face
i was like
like turn him around and i was like that
and that was like very because i didn't
have a lot of confidence before that but
once i hit it i was like oh i can hit
i can hit him okay you can land the
punches i can land the punches yeah i
think i think alex said something
similar i asked him i met him the other
day and i was like when did you think
you'd want it he was like you said
something along the lines of like i
landed one jab and it was like oh okay
and it's like i i know i'll do it again
yeah oh i'll just do that i just gotta
do that
i imagine when you [ __ ] see the guy
doing like a a kind of uh punch-out kind
of falling over wobble yeah yeah all
right i think i'm pretty good like i
think it's going well yeah
there was a point where i was like
getting mad i i don't like the camera
didn't really catch it because i'm glad
i like hit him with
one shot like right hand i was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you were hitting me
in [ __ ]
i'm gonna use that energy though right
yeah yeah
what do you mean you're not just a
sandbag taking my punches
oh my god that's crazy around it got a
lot better yeah i mean yeah you looked
amazing and it i think the whole event
was just so [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah i
i like props to everyone who like said
yes because i mean did you know going
into it like how big of a deal it was
gonna be no no he was just like you
wanna do a boxing thing right right you
must not have like known it was gonna
turn out that way yeah it did not no
idea yeah i didn't know it was gonna be
that big or that serious yeah ian's a
madman dude yeah yeah yeah he took it
very seriously he's very good yeah
massive props [ __ ] brought like
everyone up with him though with how
serious he's doing which is like really
respectable considering
like the youtube boxing scene nowadays
yeah it kind of feels like a clown show
sometimes you know
now there's like i think three more like
more serious events going to pop up soon
uh inspired by like the yeah stuff so
hell yeah
it's gonna be like leaks like there's
the best league it's like oh if you're a
big youtuber in the big one
everyone under that bar of interest 10
million yeah it's like instead of
instead of getting like a shitty plaque
and you get 100k they're like odd go and
join the little leagues
susan watches you
also glass
[Music]
that sounds good that's awesome that
sounds great
it's like the next generation gladiator
yeah
i mean that's basically what it's
turning into right yeah
because it's just like fun to see your
favorite creators do like a totally new
thing oh [ __ ] yeah they would they was
weird seeing like ian and even like like
ryan go up there it's really cool matt
yeah for his fight yeah that was great
when did you find out who your opponent
was um
like uh like a few weeks after i agreed
i think they were looking for someone
for me for a while yeah um he was gonna
put me against [ __ ] captain sparkles
who has been boxing for like years
and he's like watching for years and
he's like 80 pounds heavier than me
so you just die
not only that i don't think the boxing
commission would have let us fight i had
to like be within 10 pounds of gram i
actually was i so i went to florida i
think i was like 124 i got to florida
check the next day i was like
122. and then
on the day before the weigh-in they're
like okay go on the scale just to see to
make sure because graham was like 129.
okay right uh no no he's one like 32.
and
i was like 119. i lost so much like
water weight in florida and so like the
hour before the thing non-stop drinking
water
needing to piss so bad i gained like
i think i gained three and a half pounds
in one hour just by drinking water oh
and drink like enough water yeah yeah
yeah yeah full of piss
get punched
i needed a piss so bad before the fight
yeah um but what happens they they'll
wrap your hands and the boxing
commission has to sign off on it and
then gloves and they have to sign off on
it so you can't take them off
so i was like man i kind of got a piss
but what am i gonna do and the guy who
was like warming me up who was michael's
friend he was like
i got you i've done this before and we
[ __ ] and he's like come on anyway go
in the bathroom and i have like my card
on and my pants and he's like okay i'm
just gonna i got you and he just grabbed
it and like stood behind me and pulled
it down and i had to like use the thumbs
of the boxing gloves
and so i just like stood there pissing
and he was like holding it
in america it's like a drinking game oh
that's that sounds pretty good
okay yeah so that's what it sounds like
to me yeah yeah
just like so so what's edward forty
hands is it it's the same thing same
thing yeah inside of hands because we
call edward side of hands in australia
okay and americans said with 40 hands
right yeah because you're drinking 40s
yeah like a bottle of 40 ounces yeah so
basically you get like a bottle of cider
or 40s like literally taped on to your
hands and you've got to finish it
uh before you can take them off so at
one point you're gonna need to go to
piss
and it's it's it's really really [ __ ]
difficult just drink one right hopefully
and then hopefully you you can you can
pee yeah dude i'd [ __ ] lose that [ __ ]
like my blood my bladder is like [ __ ]
tiny my bladder is absolutely all my
skill i had i had a weird thing where it
like felt like it popped one time like i
had to piss really bad at this
restaurant yeah with the bladder popped
and i was like in the end of a line yeah
and i went to the bathroom it took super
long and like as i like you know how you
kind of suck in and you're like taking
your hands off and like i'm not sucking
it was like
i like felt something and like my vision
started getting like
black around the eyes oh my god
just like very painful and dizzy and i
finished the piss and i went out and i
sat on the ground for like 10 minutes
and but then i was fine but i think i
can't hold as much piss after that
it's like i permanently sacrifice
permanently
you just debuffed your bladder even
though i have to piss so bad it's water
are you in your toilet now you're going
to talk about it
let's take a toilet
this episode is sponsored by gamer subs
gamers gamers gamers do you want to feel
energized but also healthy at the same
time yeah well gamer subs is the drink
for you did you know that gamer subs is
a zero calorie energy formula keto and
diabetic friendly guilt-free healthy
energy drink that you can drink
throughout the day that keeps you calm
and alert each serving contains organic
caffeine vitamins minerals antioxidants
but no fillers or [ __ ] ingredients
that's wow
wow it's designed for long gaming
sessions but it's also great to get
through the day without a crash connor
are you doing gamer stops bro you know i
am i've had a game 24 7. that's how i
know you're a real gamer connor you know
i'm a gamer i shove it off my ass if i
need to come on guys get kicked through
the body quicker that way
but guys did you know gamer subs is
having a christmas in july sale starting
july 24th if you buy a type of gamer
subs you get a free waifu cup man
they're bringing double christmas this
year that's right and just for you guys
watching you can use our code trash
taste at checkout for those extra
bonuses the color gamer smash that link
in the description down below back to
the episode i've heard a rumor that you
uh you love british food i love british
food too that's crazy i think jelly to
eel is probably on the west side of
sussex
probably my favorite yeah no one eats
jelly deal you know that yeah yeah they
do i saw it on food youtube channels
that one british bloke that runs that it
was fun yeah in the east end
with the gravy and the pie did you try
it with the you don't like the coffee
like my taste buds must be fun yeah i
love how there's like so many like foods
that it's like this this food is here
because of like in the war time like we
can't eat real meat and it's like
[ __ ] not in the war now eat real food
most british stuff has some kind of
yeah we were desperate so we made this
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
it stayed around for some reason i love
beans and toast though i've said this on
the episode with lily but i actually
[ __ ] love beans
it's good
no one actually just eats beans and only
toast you put like cheese you put like a
fried egg on it and then you put like
some sauce oh
it's so good
this is good wait what are you eating
what are you doing do you like beans in
general um
do you like beans i'm i'm okay as a side
as a side okay so that's the funny thing
in the uk i cannot like stress how often
beans are eaten like it's very often
yeah it's like every side it goes with
like pretty much every british cuisine
every restaurant will have beans on the
side yeah somewhere yeah for no no
not really mine you want to come to the
uk
no
no i don't think so for like it's like
anything really are you this i don't
know it's kind of like how do you think
about how do you feel about um ireland
fun i love [ __ ] love ireland yeah i
[ __ ] love ireland it's like
it's it's like up there with japan for
like one of the most aesthetic countries
i've ever been to because like in japan
you go anywhere and it's like you take a
picture and it's like [ __ ] instagram
worthy it's the same thing in ireland
you can just drive around so green yeah
he's never been to wales that's why yeah
wales is the same wasn't this yeah yeah
yeah i'm from wales yeah yeah do you
know where wales is
yeah welshman yeah that's it that's it
because
some people think it's like a [ __ ]
city in england or something no i know
it's a country okay i mean that's more
than most yeah yeah have you been to
wales no i've never been here i've never
been in europe why would you know why
did more people not talk about whales
they're terrible at branding is is is
their tourism like just just [ __ ]
because they're [ __ ] at brandy island
they had guinness and then they were
like if you want to get drunk come here
yeah because i've heard so well off
there i've heard the same thing about
scotland as well where scotland's like a
beautiful [ __ ] country you've got the
whiskey there as well what does wells
have sheep lots and lots of sheep so is
new zealand
yeah but like it's literally too far
like
who the [ __ ] wants to go to new zealand
i want to go to new zealand yeah because
you're australian it's like what like a
like a car that's a clothes
still [ __ ] far away but it's
beautiful oh uk is nice but i feel like
if you don't drink it's kind of boring
yeah so that's a see that's a red flag
is the thing you need to be drunk to
enjoy something then you don't actually
enjoy it no no no no no no no no being
drunk it's about like everything is
designed around you do it with a drink
yeah it's not so that you get drunk it's
like okay you want to do donuts where
you've got to drink when you play yeah
darts sober yeah yeah like every every
activity you do there is paired with
drinking
in some way shape or form i i see the
denial
i understand it's emblematic of a larger
issue
well what if you go round one with
drinks in those drink holders i mean i
like that yeah
[Music]
the british philosophy is every activity
can be made more fun
right right yeah see america is in its
infancy right it's still like what 200
something years old
yeah so they haven't got like the
depression age yet where they realize
just [ __ ] give up let's just drink it
yeah i'm doing i'm getting there so the
uk has just been like oh [ __ ] man yeah
this church has been for like 900 years
you may as well [ __ ] drink in it yeah
i don't know
father may i yeah i'm pretty sure that's
why you know religion like christianity
did so well because the wine i'm pretty
like if that wasn't in it yeah you think
you think british people would like take
on that you're not going to [ __ ]
sunday mass and being like yo let me
nick this like when they leave sunday
like down to the pub people like so like
people just go to the pub like elderly
people over the age of like 50 yeah from
like 12 o'clock and they just start
drinking 12 o'clock is uh a bit late oh
yeah i've heard from sydney when she
because uh my wife worked at like a
british pub and
before the pub opened there would be
like old guys waiting queueing to get in
this pub at like 8 a.m oh my gosh and
they'd order like a double whiskey on
the rocks when they come in that's kind
of cool that's kind of cool
i want to be there at that age
like what are you doing today bob
nothing else just pump that's what they
do because that's where you see your
friends in the uk when you're like that
old yeah yeah yeah but like i've i've
seen some people just sitting there at
the pub on their own oh yeah as well so
they're not even going to the pub to
like convert what's aussie culture like
pretty much the same
so except no except for us it's if if
the if it's too early to go to the pub
you just go to the beach yeah yeah
you're drinking at the beach yourself
drinking the beach is the [ __ ] best
except you can't do it in a lot of
beaches in australia so never mind that
in
oh
hawaii
feel like they would have been like
super strict yeah i don't know i've
never gotten in trouble
that went from so confident
everyone does it so yeah yeah yeah i i
went to uh a pub with a friend for
dinner uh
lunch so no breakfast even breakfast
like 11.
one of the meals holidays very early
because this guy came in ordered three
beers drank them all on his own and then
just left and i was like i was like what
are you doing the day started yeah yeah
he like dropped his kids off somewhere
finally
i can just leave it is very like
depressing
yeah
yeah that's i think that's why we are
the way we are
everyone cynical and you know just
miserable but in like a fun charming way
yeah
we're very self-deprecating yeah yeah
yeah which is what i was going to say
with our humor it's just kind of with
life with everything i love cringe humor
so much oh yeah like i don't know if
you've ever watched any british tv shows
or
yeah i've seen a couple have you ever
seen peep show no oh that's good you
should have seen in between us
oh my god you should watch these
pinnacles
british television fan
i don't watch any tv really really not
like now no anime did you watch anything
uh anime like the last anime i watched
through was probably like mob psycho i
mean that's honestly that's
i remember that uh i think we
briefly spoke because you liked banana
fish oh i love banana fish me too but
like it's just one of those shows where
it was really underappreciated and
people didn't really talk about it i'm
surprised you watched banana fish
because most anime fans don't know about
banana fish quite liked that yeah
i think it was just
oh if you're a girl and you like seeing
hot guys have problems well like it was
intentional like twice that was it yeah
but it was a it was a [ __ ] awesome
show it was besides that yeah it was
super cool including that made elevated
by that sure i think it elevated it i
mean yeah it was hot it was epic
what other anime have you watched i mean
we obliterally have to talk about it
because yeah because we are attending
anime nothing really good not not a lot
of anime right joey then yeah yeah join
the club yeah
i watched a few episodes of that spy x
family show which was pretty good quite
good i also enjoy food yeah yeah
was that uh um
had netflix uh
i don't know if that was an animal
arcade no
yeah yes my favorite anime did you like
did you like arcane i loved arcade yeah
me too that was excellent that's great
i had to do it joey i had to do it use
this to watch it right it's just funny
it's just funny to see like arcane fans
just get pissed off whenever i say that
it is excellent it's a good one um no it
was called uh the great pretender oh
yeah what's the great
that was a good [ __ ] show that was
[ __ ] awesome yeah yeah
but like a good good [ __ ] show yeah
the way through yeah that was probably
the last one
yeah i guess because like i guess it's
it sounds like you watch like a wide
variety of animals just from like
different sources because like banana
fish is like really really [ __ ]
underground apparently yeah how the [ __ ]
is this yeah yeah yeah i don't know it
just came on i i forget where i heard of
it it was good i um
was in the in the mag club in high
school because my friend was the
yeah
yeah you can't have your separate clubs
it was a bad school it wasn't a great
school
well it's not like it i mean it was a
smaller school so there's like a harry
potter club of mine yeah just for harry
potter that's [ __ ] up
nice were you in that [ __ ] no
i don't know you brought it up so i
thought you had some stories the movies
were over at that point i wonder what
they were still talking about
i can't wait fantastic beasts jk rowling
[ __ ] up on twitter again i don't think
so
yeah no yeah i watched the first anime i
ever saw was death note and i would
watch it in my stem class at lunch
because they didn't have a vpn up at the
school right you
they're going to watch season three when
it comes out i didn't know they were
doing a season yeah
it's coming out this year or next year
because they're gonna be the final one
because it's gonna be the final season
yeah that's sick
no i didn't know that
you joined this audio listeners
you guys ever do this no well i mean yes
not on the show
[Music]
you're gonna you're gonna pop it you're
gonna pop it yeah yeah you've done i've
never seen this before it's kind of this
is giving me really anxiety now
it's my what
i've never st i've never seen that smoke
before my glasses what the hell you can
do with any bottle
a little uh story that you uh when you
got the
boston dynamics dog thing yeah you still
own that right yeah that's around what
do you do with it it's at the offline tv
house right now does it do anything or
um not really
i'm still thinking of [ __ ] to do with it
so just like sitting there just like
he's just waiting to be turned on again
oh no she's like exhausted crying yeah i
see him every time i walk up the stairs
he's like under the staircase oh harry
potter yeah
so did you get that specifically for the
piss robot video idea or did you just
get one and was like i gotta make it it
was like a joint thing with offline tv
right and we all got it together and
then i was like i'll use it for this
this sounds awesome that was right so
you convinced them to pay
yeah because we used it in a couple of
offline tv videos oh really yeah okay so
it was kind of a tax write-off nice this
is mainland
can we get a dog
i want a pet
but a very specific kind of pet
[Music]
our manager ladies and gentlemen okay um
so i'm going to
i don't know we probably haven't
announced this i'm going we're going to
japan yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh i like running off into the
night and doing things i have some
questions about japan okay um if i want
to ride us a motorcycle or a scooter can
i do that can i rent one no no no no no
what if i have an international driver's
license maybe they have the uh i can
apply for that it's different they have
those like ride on right off like
scooters now like electric scooters that
you can drive on the road yeah now so if
you sign up for the apps and you have a
driver's license i'm pretty sure you can
that's cool yeah i think it's like a cc
thing like a power thing yeah like
anything under like a certain cc might
be allowed yeah i believe so when you
get like a bicycle in japan you have to
register it with the police
a bicycle yeah yeah you have to register
a bicycle why yeah japan loves [ __ ]
rules there's rules for everything that
sucks yeah i mean it's like the i guess
you get this like do you want to get
like arrested for not having your
bicycle i don't know what does you get
you get your bike confiscated it's like
a fine i think if you get found out you
get found out so japan loves rules yeah
and they love rules so much and that's
why everything works really nicely yeah
you're just like you're just like i just
wanted to ride a bicycle i didn't want
to have to go to the police
but that's why i do the rental bicycle
things yeah yeah which are like
everywhere in tokyo yeah so much better
yeah so like after living in japan i've
realized the way the country works is if
you want to do something
um and you ask someone for permission
for it 99 of the time they're going to
say no yeah because they don't know if
you're allowed to do it or not so
they're just going to say no but if you
do something
then there's only like i guess a 50 50
chance that someone's going to call you
out on it all right yeah it's not the
way it works right
in japan yeah like if like you know
there's plenty of irl streamers yeah you
know they never ask for permission yeah
yeah but you know whenever we do main
channel videos or big things we have to
get permission and it's it's a nightmare
japan is literally better to ask for
forgiveness than no not just like asked
to do something yeah very different
let's get permission to film in a lot of
places because they just they just don't
like no that's yeah that's tough yeah
man
yeah it's just the culture yeah that's
how it is there's ways around it yeah
yeah you get amazing you know the trains
turn up on time and you so i guess it
kind of works kind of like all right
yeah everything else works i'll try to
find a scooter
what is what is it that you want to do
in japan then i just want to scoot
around around i just want to see all the
stuff yeah they have the scooter rental
thing something yeah sucks we're not
there when you guys are there yeah that
is tough we're kind of doing trading
spaces wife swap type thing yeah yeah we
all right like yeah yeah could have
showed you around yeah yeah yeah
literally everyone's coming to japan
when we are out of japan yeah it's like
it's it's a [ __ ] mass exodus on both
sides yeah it's so sad i am really
excited for it though i think have you
ever been yes once before okay it was
amazing what did you do there before uh
we went around shibuya i think shinjuku
um tried out the amazing food try not
meat that was oh so good [ __ ] any
yoshinoy is just good
hell yeah to me
it is it is it is good
as [ __ ] uh yeah
yeah we did a lot of stuff uh seeing
mount fuji was amazing yeah yeah one of
the most beautiful
things ever so picturesque yeah it's
it's it's it's like unfair how like
pictures and aesthetic it is it's like
god just like perfectly crafted yeah
yeah just perfect symmetry just a little
something on top yeah yeah let's just
add a little cherry on top yeah i woke
up on the bus and i was like oh this
like it's god that's god
that's like why religion exists
like there is like some lakes around
mount fuji where you walk around and it
literally looks like just it's so
beautiful it literally looks fake yeah i
thought we were at one of those lakes so
it's really beautiful yeah because it
looks like it just looks like it looks
like unreal engine yeah
it looks like a desktop wallpaper could
look like rendered in here okay
unreal engine fire on rtx on
it how long are you guys going to be
there for um a while like two weeks
solid two weeks yeah
it's gonna be awesome i i think i might
um just branch off and because probably
my favorite part about japan last time
was
um just being by myself in a crowd of
people and no one knowing anything yeah
just being a [ __ ] cog in a machine
was nice that's what it's like
yeah that was cool it was cool like just
like yeah just like floating around in
crowded areas and going to different
places it's just like the opposite of
l.a like everyone in la like every
single person you meet it's like you're
talking to like somebody who believes
they're the main character yeah like in
every sense and then in japan it's like
i'm just here to do my part yeah yeah
i'm just gonna exist and not get in the
way yeah yeah like it's really like it's
refreshing coming here but then after a
while you're like okay this is too much
yeah i want to go back yeah it's weird
it's definitely strange being in america
now yeah yeah
i'm already [ __ ] sick of the customer
service here or i guess the lack thereof
oh is it because uh yeah because i mean
i i feel like we've been spoiled so much
living in japan like with like amazon or
like just going to a [ __ ] restaurant
or whatever but um like yeah i what i
thought was normal like next day
delivery yeah on amazon i thought that
was just normal
not not here apparently unless you want
to pay like [ __ ] triple the shoes
yeah it's two days two-day delivery yeah
but in japan it's like 99 times out of a
hundred it's being next time i guess it
makes sense this is little island i
guess it checks out i guess fishing
is no joke shipping very seriously yeah
how are the other islands i quite liked
your um biking video oh yeah oh yeah if
you're able to go i mean it's a bit out
of the way from tokyo but yeah it's like
one of i'm not gonna do it yeah
it looks cool it was it was like [ __ ]
beautiful we somehow like lucked out on
that day
so perfect it was october as well i
think yeah yeah
october yeah it was like october october
the perfect kind of like all right
because when you're going in july that's
it's horrible yeah it's just disgusting
oh you're going in july be careful about
the uh heat and the humidity i grew up
in hawaii i've been in the philippines
in july so it's okay it'll be all right
it's it's gross yeah it's disgusting
yeah cycling was perfect it was like
nice clear like low humidity and it was
just great i mean it's kind of stressful
because you want to focus more on just
cycling but when you're filming and it
was just us three and two other guys so
we're just trying to get this thing yeah
to look and sound good yeah so you're
constantly stopping like is it are the
camera's okay are the gopro is okay yeah
you just change batteries hey i need
batteries yeah so you do this cycling
thing that should be down in like six
hours but it takes like 12. yeah yeah
everything is doubled when you're
filming yeah just so i'm sure i mean you
do a bunch of stuff with uh offline tv
right yeah so i'm sure stuff is would be
fun if you could just do it off camera
yeah but it's like okay we're gonna redo
that again okay let's check it out they
do a pretty good job of like setting up
um
offline tv is very hands off for like uh
when you're in the like they they handle
a lot of it yeah oh yeah we kind of do
most of it yeah yeah
yeah it's like a complete like i do
everything for myself channel and all
that yeah and i know it's well it's
cause like it was like especially in
japan uh when we first started trash
taste like the influencer and content
creator like infrastructure just wasn't
there so even if we wanted to hire a
specialist in x y or z to help us make
content it was so hard you just you just
couldn't find it for like for like for
longest time whereas in la it seems like
you guys are able to just get
specialists for like any area and if and
if they did exist then they were most
likely just like only japanese speaking
only understand the japanese content
creator side of things which is just
completely different to the [ __ ] we do
yeah yeah right so it's like just trying
to explain that to them being like no
we're not gonna do it the japanese way
yeah we're gonna do it the the
non-japanese way they're just like what
do you mean yeah is there a difference
it's like impossible finding some type
of people that we want to do certain
things yeah cause they just don't exist
in japan yeah because you need somebody
speaks english happens to be in japan
already and is doing that and then is
available to do it yeah yeah like all
right like which is like nobody yeah
especially right now yeah there's no one
yeah maybe when the country opens up a
little bit it'll be a little easier yeah
so so like for the cycling video it was
a lot of it was just like guesswork by
us and it was like a [ __ ] miracle i
think it just miraculously happened to
be something that was cohesive yeah yeah
yeah
how was the youtube
over there do they do a lot there's one
youtuber i really like over there his
name is sushi ramen yeah because he's
just a japanese version of you yeah
he's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah um i
don't know i don't watch a whole lot of
japanese youtubers but like i'd say
sushi ram is probably the most
interesting yeah yeah yeah he's
definitely the most interesting yeah a
lot of the japanese stuff is just like
they're trying to rip off japanese tv
yeah it's really not good yeah
thumbnails are [ __ ] awful yeah yeah
their thumbnail game in japanese
[ __ ]
but like who else can you compete with
because the japanese market is so
isolated yeah like they they progress
for youtube trends completely different
from the rest of the world yeah so when
you watch it it's so like bizarre seeing
this completely like singular yeah yeah
it's really interesting yeah i mean a
lot of japanese people if they speak
english they're like oh just gonna do
english because yeah it makes way more
sense yeah exactly of course it's yeah
it's kind of it's interesting yeah i
mean like the creator like field or just
the creator community there it's like
pretty small especially compared to
somewhere like l.a but i mean it's
slowly growing slowly growing slowly
yeah slow there's a decent amount of
english channels doing videos yeah i'm
sure if you've seen like any you've
already seen a bunch i don't know yeah
probably yeah
i mean the jvlogging scene's coming back
right yeah but i mean everyone's in
different places
because [ __ ] felix moved down started
making j vlogs right that's that's this
is what happens
and then all the jvloggers came out of
their bunkers they're like we can make
jvlogs again okay
that's good though because like when did
when did you move to la again
like four years ago four years ago i'm
like that yeah how are you finding it
lah it's all right
now this city [ __ ] sucks this is his
ass that's what everyone says yeah yeah
but i can't leave the people i can't
wait to leave
the industry you already heard it yeah
heard it all right it's just the people
i know live here even my like i
convinced like my friends from high
school to move here right um
and like and they're like what have you
done what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
yeah i'm broke my rent is too high
everything's broken
i'm trying to like explore more of it um
because i i'd like to know where i am
yeah um so i've been going around doing
more [ __ ] um like riding
like
uh like
bird scooters as much as i can around
areas yeah bikes and stuff yeah yeah
yeah so it's i think the problem is just
like la is just not built for like
scooters and bikes no it's both for the
car it's built for cars right because
i've been to like european cities where
i've tried out the scooters yeah just
really really [ __ ] fun and useful and
it's more useful than cars involved
so
like
it's it's it's hard because i i when i
like to explore places i like to like
walk places yeah
for walking yeah
like everywhere else as a city it's like
oh the downtown is the cool place but
like downtown ali is like just
terrifying don't do anything there it's
not even fun like you're not even
risking it for a benefit it's just bad
yeah so before like this trip i pretty
much have only been to like the downtown
side of la because that was where like
anime explores so we would only have
like a few days around anime expo so the
only places to explore is basically like
little tokyo and downtown l.a
and it was
i think everyone has a different
experience and has a different story
with shitty things that have happened in
downtown people yeah downtown it's
awesome yeah it's it's like this is the
best country
best town ever if you want to like
people watch yeah because like there's
just the strangest people
existing yeah
la and new york like the top also has
some good [ __ ] yeah portland has some
crazy [ __ ] happening wait really maybe
more than downtown l.a why i don't know
um i've been in portland once and like
walking on the street
like i was there for like one day and i
got like voodoo donuts which is like a
famous donut place in la and this like
dude walks up to me and he's like can i
have that and i was like eating this it
was called [ __ ] and balls and it was a
donut shape like a dick and balls and i
was like you know what i'm done with it
yeah you can have it and i like it's in
the napkin and it's like in a rapper and
he's like oh thanks and he [ __ ]
grabbed it by the shaft
and i took it out of my hand it was
crazy oh dude my friend my friend
goblin on the wall yeah my friend gabe
lives in portland and he said he
he had this great story he went like on
the train
right
this like homeless person came up to him
and he was like hello ken
the guy said hi can i shake your hand
and my friend was like
usually just doesn't shake hands with
random people but the whole train looked
at him yeah everyone was looking at him
he's like okay i gotta kind of do this
or else i'm an [ __ ] and he's like he
said he like slow motion saw the hand
coming and then he shaked it and the guy
said i have aids
[Music]
his first thing
what did he say after that apparently
they talked to the end of the thing like
about like how he has aids a little bit
yeah
but just his life
holy [ __ ] quite an okay conversation
yeah yeah america is scary america's
weird yeah yeah i had something similar
happened to me on the uk tube though
yeah oh yeah yeah i had like uh the so
the uk metro in london i i went on
because i was going uh somewhere i think
i was heading to your place
maybe or somewhere in london but some
homeless dude came up to me and he was
like uh excuse me sir and then he pulls
his shirt up and there's just like a
giant [ __ ] laceration like this big
and he's just bleeding from it and he's
like i just got stabbed
and uh i need hospital funds
and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
and so so like you know and again same
situation everyone in the tube is
looking at me and i'm like well i can't
say no no so i just gave him like a one
pound yeah that's what it is
i got just stopped he is a powerball
he's a fan
hospital funds we're in the [ __ ] uk
yeah what are we talking about yeah yes
yeah right so i just like i gave it to
him and then he's like thank you and
then i thought about i'm like
isn't it free yeah in the uk yeah yeah i
mean luckily i didn't give him like a
tape i mean he deserved it but he was
like
i could see it was like clearly not like
makeup it was like full-on he got
you get stabbed first thing you do start
going to ask him for money
what is this
i was like i was expecting that [ __ ] in
america not the uk i'm just conditioned
in the uk whenever anyone like talks to
me like no yeah
yeah yeah because like if someone starts
talking to you in the uk something's
gone wrong yeah you just said yeah yeah
you say like no
it's like in japan when someone starts
talking to you it's like oh my trouble
yeah
because
yeah yeah they should leave you alone
that's the whole country's design
yeah
yeah especially in london as well
because i remember like when i first
moved to london uh i was like you know
trying to be really polite i was on the
tube i was like letting people you know
letting people go in front of me if they
needed to go or something and like
within a month of moving to london i was
like [ __ ] pushing kids out the way if
someone if someone like stood on like
the left side of like the [ __ ]
escalator i i i think i put out a hit on
them you know because in england if you
stand you always have to stand on the
right side of the escalator always
remember that and it's like i actually
like messed up because in japan it's
like it's left side right and i remember
standing on the left side in london when
i went back this time
and i i didn't i forgot and someone like
tried to like [ __ ] bust past me right
i felt i felt like the shame man i felt
the shame
i betrayed myself man in tokyo it's the
left but in osaka it's the right
yeah yeah in west japan you stand on the
right side but in east japan you stand
on the left side i don't know why
it doesn't make any sense called grids
are different
yeah
yeah it's gotta go on the right
i remember
uh i've watched your channel since like
pretty much the very first video you did
oh yeah i remember when your whole thing
was being the guy with the laser laser
guy yeah yeah that was like your whole
thing for a while that was fun when you
made that did you think [ __ ] dude i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep making all these
videos and become a youtuber nah that
was like one of the ones where it was
like um just gonna make it for fun it'd
be cool i was in college at the time i
was very sad miserable um i wanted
something to do so i like college i used
like trash and pizza boxes to make it i
used like people throw away their
microwaves so i like took them apart i
would take them from the dumpster and
like oh my god i like got the
transformer it really didn't do anything
it was like the weight for it um but
yeah it was like made out of garbage and
i did not expect it to do anything i
just wanted to put it somewhere because
i've been watching youtube forever so i
was like may as well make one yeah it
definitely seemed like you had
inspirations when you started yeah yeah
i watched a lot of youtubers yeah
who are your inspirations specifically
um
i don't know i would watch just a lot of
i watch a lot of like filthy frank
yeah
of course yeah
yeah that was the best time that was the
best time on youtube ever yeah
like i think it's the best
because it's like it's just like a dude
with the [ __ ] camera and like mr
beast is cool and [ __ ] but like he's got
like a production world around him and
like he's got like a team of 20 people
doing [ __ ] at all times yeah and like
filthy friend was just like hey i got
that i got the phone just a guy with a
camera i'm gonna say some horrible [ __ ]
he was just a dude in a filthy apartment
yeah yeah that's what i like about it um
i i definitely like that where it's just
like see what one person with a camera
can do
is that kind of like the tribe of the
vibe you still try to emulate now where
it's just like
doing everything oh i still yeah i mean
i i just like to do it myself because
it's like it feels
more in control right but
yeah i don't do it for any specific
purpose yeah like it would definitely be
smarter to like outsource it to like
like make someone else edit it or
whatever yeah yeah um but it just i
can't i'm not good at working in a team
either right so i can't like communicate
it to them where it's like this is what
i'm going for like i just like i have to
know it and do it myself right yeah
how'd you balance like your youtube with
like your what you like you know your
twitch offline tv and everything else
then because
like if i was you i would feel like
guilty for not working on my channel all
the time just because
you like your upload schedule is like so
vast sometimes it is very long in
between yeah
not a lot of balance uh i'm just i'm
very lazy sometimes and like
yeah i'll just get like sidetracked
doing like a different hobby or trying
some other [ __ ] out and i'll be like oh
two months are gone
like i i tried to learn a little game
development recently right but it's like
especially if i'm learning something
that's always useful um
yeah not a lot of balance you're always
like leveling up somewhat somehow
hopefully yes
yeah hopefully that's how that's how i
feel something yeah exactly yeah i can't
imagine you were like super productive
after doing like five days of boxing a
week as well yeah that must have like
it took a little hit to the uh
productivity little yeah it was a tiny
little hit
yeah but now that it's off i'm doing a
little more um
yeah sometimes it's like
i've noticed that like i can
see how
the video is
like how much [ __ ] i gotta do for it
mm-hmm um but like
like when i was first starting like i
had no [ __ ] clue how much it was
gonna be but now that i see it all i'm
like [ __ ] what do i do first um
like i'm unsure of like where to start
sometimes yeah yeah yeah yeah it's uh i
mean it's all right i just like trying
to do as much as i can every day yeah
fluctuates some days it's like 12 hours
sometimes it's zero hours have you tried
to keep like the fitness that you got
during like the boxing period i'm trying
yeah i'm still like hitting up the gym
and stuff i still like having a punching
bag in my garage and all that um i'm
trying to keep up with it because it's
nice like right cause i
that was like a thing i could work
towards i will never be that fit ever
again in my life i've decided that was
my [ __ ] piece because i had a thing
to work towards and now it's like am i
gonna do that for me no you're not gonna
[ __ ] do five days a week two hours
yeah no yourself yeah that was my so i'm
like trying to maintain it as much as i
can right props then i mean
yeah the food the food was all right
you're kind of burned a lot of calories
you're kind of allowed to eat right a
lot yeah it's nice um
a lot of chicken yeah a lot of chicken a
lot of preparation you know what's one
weird thing that not a lot of people
talk about that is like a preparation
for a fight you're not supposed to nut
is that real
absolutely real i feel like this is like
a thing that boxes have been doing but
they there's no and their coaches have
been just like saying
i thought it was like a myth but there's
like no scientific proof that not
nutting makes you stronger well i i was
in the same boat i was exactly in the
same boat okay okay how long before you
knocked out enough um he said like don't
do like two weeks
two weeks i was like man i don't know if
i can do two days
and like
and i was like like a week i like i got
it to a week and i was like my [ __ ]
this is stupid
i i did and the next day at uh like at
training i was like very lethargic and
he was like
no and i was
like
don't put your hand up this guy's the
black light
and he was like um
i was like hey is something wrong with
my diet like i feel like kind of heavy
today do you think it's like something
to do with what i ate and he was like
hey level with me you know
did you not how the [ __ ] did you know
and so that that
it proved a little bit i i don't know
it's placebo or a coincidence but i did
not uh up until the fight so
that was yeah yeah and
people i haven't talked to like they
were like oh yeah they told my coach
told me the same thing it's like
something like fighting where they like
say it and like maybe try it you should
prove it i don't think i'm gonna fight a
homeless yeah
i'm not gonna nut for two more yeah i'm
in the control test
you're telling me that no not november
is actually real
you really do
that's what the ball guard is for wasn't
it yeah yeah let's keep it in a vice
yeah i just always thought that was
[ __ ] but i guess yeah
maybe there's some method behind the
madness i thought it was stupid and then
had a little proving so you know who
knows
was that was that something that
everyone did not ever well everyone had
a different coach
i found a surprising amount of people
were like yeah like alex was like yeah
my coach told me not to yeah and like a
bunch of other so it's not just my coach
being a freak and being like
thankfully it was everyone i don't know
i tell you [ __ ] anything yeah i know
yeah you'd be like dude do not [ __ ]
don't [ __ ]
i feel like they have more authority
than any of the coaches like dude i
punch people dude yeah yeah yeah dude
watch mr beast just watch it like
backwards
freak you out you'll you'll just get it
you're gonna be
[ __ ] shaking
all right be interesting to see like how
many fighters actually followed through
with that advice
privately yeah like i'm gonna leave like
did you not before you just told me i
was just like the list of the winners
and listen to losers and just like oh my
god it's true they all know
this should be a good scientific study
yeah i think they have done it and
proved that it has no correlation but
also that's in like a controlled
environment so it's hard it must be a
mental thing it must be a mental thing
but you feel like you're holding back so
you're like i don't know maybe your
body's like maybe yeah yeah testosterone
it's like something you look forward to
after the fight right but if you go
before the fight then it's not gonna
look forward what are you doing you
can't not
the reason why i'm standing in this ring
is because i know the nut afterwards is
going to be the best knot
crazy
where are you like can this fight just
end already so i can just go nut
you have to knock me out right now i
need to not asap bro i'm going for a
round one knockouts
to explode
just knock me out dude
oh my god it fits right into the trash
taste topics we always talk about
[ __ ] pissing and yeah you're
shooting pissing and nodding there's no
bidets here man [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
at my house because i i learned the
truth in japan
i did last time
yeah yeah literally yeah it just it
makes pooping just something to look
forward to like saying yes you're like
this is great for me i hate having to
white yeah i hate it so i can't i like
yeah and it's just it's just too much
time it's inefficient like now with my
bidet it's like i [ __ ] and i'm done i'm
i'm quick and you know you're clean and
you know you're good you never get that
like swarm pass later either like it's
just always like clean yeah it's good i
installed it yeah it's one of my top
three best purchases i've ever made
it's like you like modded your bidder at
all i feel like you're the kind of guy
you're like you know the jet pouch isn't
yeah so i installed a pressure washer
that man knows like the model names
he does i thought he was just joking
yeah yeah
it's like good model i just judged like
in my mind in japan you get to
experience all the different levels of
bj if it opens up and then drives my ass
as well that's how you know it's like
elite level that's right yeah yeah yeah
that's like okay [ __ ] this is not
playing it's got a hair dryer built in
yeah william has got a really good one
as well he tore his whole toilet out it
was like the full not just the seat the
hole oh yeah he told me about this yeah
like three thousand bucks
yeah yeah because we were talking about
it and he was like dude it changed my
life
it's like it's like a cult like
everyone's got it it's a religious
experience yeah if when you have it you
can never go back yeah it's like it's
got water warmer in there and it's like
it doesn't feel that it feels weird like
when you first started yeah like then
you're over it and it's good yeah yeah
did you visit to many uh ryokans when
you went to or like onsen when you went
to japan no we didn't visit any you
should do that i think we will i think
we're going to go to like yeah that's
that's one of the biggest things we
recommend when going to japan
that's also another religious experience
yeah find a really good one get that
moment where you're like boys all right
we'll all look and we'll get over it
yeah it's like five seconds
yeah honest now i can't go back because
actually when i'm like what about now i
stay every time yeah
cause like i went to the uk i went to
bathroom which is like a very like
famous spa city in the uk so we actually
like stayed in like a spa hotel and they
had like a they had like a pool and like
hot tubs and public baths there yeah
right um and then you go in and i've
never felt so unclean going into a
public bath with trunks on
i don't know man
japan has conditioned me now to think i
need to be [ __ ] naked to be in like
hot water you get really used to it yeah
you do really fast about like going yeah
public bath people now like your friends
you're like yeah let's just go yeah it's
whatever you get used to i don't know
that's cool i like that like we've all
got dudes it's like a bro yeah yeah it's
like a bonding moment as well yeah yeah
you don't like specifically look at it
you're just like no it's there you know
yeah it's a it's in my periphery yeah
you go with another content creator
you're like well you know i know that
we're trustworthy because i could just
tell everyone about how big that dick is
yeah
there's like there's some people trust
me yeah they're [ __ ] in here and audi
yeah yeah you're like oh yeah how big
are their balls
yeah
i know yeah let me just
check for cancer
oh my god that's pretty cool yeah maybe
i think we do have that in the itinerary
so yeah it's it's a very fun experience
yeah yeah i think we always try and go
to them when we're traveling around
japan yeah
it's just like you get a really
authentic experience of like an old
japanese woman like forcing you to eat
food that you don't really want to eat
yeah like yeah he got woken up you got
like rudely woken up right yeah i had
like there was a real kind i went to
where basically the wake-up call for
breakfast is 8 a.m but i got stupidly
drunk the night before yeah right
because it's like a full-on japanese
meal with like sake and everything so
it's like obviously you're gonna go ham
yeah so i was hung over [ __ ] because
sake gives me the worst hangovers it's
like eight o'clock she's like knocking
on the door she's like calling the phone
it's like oh your breakfast is ready and
i'm like yeah all right [ __ ] off and
then she just the woman just walks into
my hotel room and literally strips the
[ __ ] blanket
off me like a mob like your mom is like
[ __ ] wake up it's breakfast and i'm
like
it's like dude i'm paying like hundreds
of dollars for you to do this like this
is not this is not okay but they because
you pay so much money they like and a
lot of the costs with royal cans is like
in the food is the food yeah yeah and if
you don't show up they get like actually
angry yeah they're like you better
[ __ ] show up and they'll non-stop
ringing you if you're not there yeah
oh yeah the dinner is always amazing but
the breakfast is so 50 50.
it's either [ __ ] amazing or it's a
chore to go through yeah and it's just
there's no in between it never ends no
they're just like all right his his 15
different types of radish with slime all
right next up we got another slimy thing
all right next up we got some tofu so
and you're like [ __ ] man
i literally just woke up yeah yeah i
can't eat this one's not a breakfast
person
no yeah
i don't think any of us are breakfast
people you're right you do you want to
eat the moment you wake up no i have to
force myself to eat like a peanut butter
bagel and that's it right because no one
[ __ ] i feel like we're not designed
to eat immediately when we wake up
that's why the biggest anomaly for me in
la is breakfast burritos dude okay
breakfast foods are good though they're
good but also
they're not breakfast though yeah right
but it's like how do you [ __ ] eat
this much food in the morning yeah right
yeah it's a it's a lot of food breakfast
breakfast breakfast burritos is the same
way as the same thing as like a full
english or an american breakfast where
you could like when you have it you just
rolled it they just rolled it up huh
they just rolled they just rolled it up
right
yeah i mean i'd love it i just i could
not eat it every every day that's like
[ __ ] that yeah that's like two meals
yeah great hangover food though again
yeah great hangout great [ __ ]
hangover food yeah dude i was so
hungover after the credit clash thing i
had to move my flight the next oh i can
imagine that was hot
yeah there was there was a nice one at
charlie's house oh no i got very people
are very drunk yeah it was nice because
we weren't supposed to drink like before
it yeah yeah yeah yeah i think uh minks
told me that was the hardest thing yeah
she's an alcoholic
i mean i like drinking but i'd be like
[ __ ] i gotta not drink for four months
my boys want to hang out yeah [ __ ] dude
no drinking and no nutty yeah
yeah yeah i throw a bunch of [ __ ] on
there okay good then yeah
okay good i was like [ __ ] if it's just
like grilled chicken yeah no i can't do
that yeah i'd be like [ __ ] i got that
religious about it
but i mean how was living in uh hawaii
because i've never met anyone who's
lived in hawaii it's quite good um very
different than the rest of the united
states were you on the main island the
big island i was not on the big island
so this is the big island which is the
biggest one then there's one called the
wahoo which is the most populated one so
that's like the main one people good i
was on maui which is like kind of a
cross
like there's like tourism is very nice
um but there's also like a lot of nature
so i like living yeah yeah the nature
it's quite nice there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] that happened there like um stuff
that is normal when you grow up there
and then not normal anywhere else like
like
like um
they're like they're very it's like one
of the most liberal states but they love
guns they love hunting which is cool all
right
um when i would go to school um a couple
of times my p.e teacher was like i went
to an outdoor school right like i went
to a school yeah so it's not like an ins
because the weather's you know always
like yeah yeah so it's like it's like
it's like multiple buildings um so it's
not just one building it's like
connected by outdoor pathways oh yeah i
mean
yeah yeah yeah you made it sound like
the school didn't have a roof no no it
was in the jungle
it's like
outdoors
it's like mud huts and everything like
that yeah
technology
videos
yeah it was uh i would go sometimes like
a couple times i'd go do my pe class
yeah and my pe teacher would be like
skinning a [ __ ] fish on the lawn in
front of the class that he had caught
that morning
it was so [ __ ] weird like especially
in retrospect it was like he's skinning
a fish the kids he'd like he'd be like
hey you want fish and he this [ __ ]
like 14 year olds would have a a quart
gallon sized bag of lukewarm fish on the
bus home that i'm just this fat [ __ ]
thing of non-refrigerated fish on the
bus
that muscle like stank up
i was going to school on the bus
and we saw a deer got hit by a car and
was just dead on the side of the road
yeah and
it was taking the bus home this dumb-ass
kid from our class had picked it up and
was carrying it back home
he let him get on the bottom like oh no
he wasn't on the bus he was walking so
we saw the kids who were walking for on
the bus oh my god
he just had it over his shoulders like a
[ __ ] freak like bringing it home to
his family it doesn't sound like the us
like it sounds like it's just part of
the us but yeah it doesn't seem like
it's it's very it's definitely different
from here it's not like it's not like
the boonies or anything like there's
electricity in the internet of course of
course yeah we got houses yeah obviously
yeah the functioning missile system
systems yeah
yeah
um it is just like complete
like very different culture yeah yeah i
mean it must be like quite refreshing
then coming to the mainland u.s and
you're like wow i didn't really want to
leave very bad because it's an island so
right
like when you grow up there you just
want to get off it yeah
yeah
we're going to leave
get us the [ __ ] out of it yeah yeah yeah
let me leave yeah that sucks too because
brutus is bad yeah yeah it's not hawaii
it's not even like a tourist yeah
exactly yeah at least like
waterfalls and stuff we can go to the
beach and drink in the beach super fun
yeah we have
um that's it yeah yeah yeah yeah we work
out the fields we have castles castles
and fields yeah there's like actually
that's pretty one of the only cool
things it's like you have like so much
history and if you're into that that's
like really cool probably sick for if
you're into history yeah like castles
there was like four castles where i grew
up yeah and that was that is pretty
[ __ ] cool to be fair yeah that was
pretty cool and then like when you leave
like when i actually don't live there
now you really do appreciate you're like
[ __ ] dude it's so cool how much
sheer amount of history you have in
every location but outside of that
you're like well there's a greg's there
in a mcdonald's yeah yeah well yeah but
at least you guys have that like you
know because there are like castles in
the uk that are easily like older than
the entirety of australia oh yeah oh
yeah
we don't have any of that [ __ ] yeah we
have like this building's been around
since the early 1900s and it's like yeah
yeah cool a lot of the castles right
where i grew up were like older like six
plus 700 years old yeah right
i wish we had that in australia we don't
have any of that [ __ ] yeah
we just have like it's like here's a
desert it's like yeah you can buy them
you can buy the castles you know a lot
of them are up for sale i've really i
really want to buy a castle but it just
feels like
what am i gonna do stream the internet's
gonna be dog [ __ ] yeah
could you install it
at that point
i own a castle you know you don't own a
house you don't own property you're in a
[ __ ] car i saw they were selling a
whole like dry moat prison uh castle
yeah oh so there's a motion yeah that's
right yeah so yeah and it was like kind
of it looked like something from like
[ __ ] alcatraz it was like off the
shores as well really cool and it was uh
it had
i loved how they were trying to sell it
they were like it's a very spacious
prison
uh renovation and like the pictures were
literally just abandoned
it's like requires renovation probably
to be [ __ ] torn down and it was going
for like a million pounds so about 1.3
million usd but it was like there's a
[ __ ] moat like how did you just go
you got a moat how are you going to get
a moat in the u.s yeah that's true i
feel like the moment you say moat i'm
like i'm interested that sounds really
cool did you have to like bring down
like a drawbridge like get people across
or no there was a bridge but the drop
there was a dry moat there as well well
then what's the point in the world which
kind of sounded kind of difficult
yeah yeah i think it must have been
changed or something or i don't know why
damn i really want i would absolutely
buy a castle just for the flex imagine
you're not just a prison a prison castle
a prison castle with a moat that sounds
cool
we're gonna miss the beast please
that's like a mr b there i bought every
castle in the uk
you could get a castle in the us just
white castle so i mean it's kind of like
yeah
why would you want to do that yeah why
would you want that that's really rough
that's pretty gross that's gross you
know what i don't understand in the us
renaissance fairs yeah that's kind of
interesting as being like when you're
british and you see those you guys don't
have those
well that's not no that's like that's
just history that's just history for us
i mean you don't you're not living it
you ever been in medieval times
uh no i've been to the pirate one really
yeah that's my friend was like dude i'm
telling you it has the best food in l.a
and so
i've like got my hopes up and it was
like the worst feat i've ever had about
yeah pirates medieval times and i was
like you think this
is good like the mashed potato tastes
like there's no beans on toast here
[ __ ] off
american people love mocking british
food because it's funny yeah but your
food is the [ __ ] worst what do you
mean we got like every country's worth
of food you go to the supermarket and
the amount of like ready-to-go meals
that look like they would poison you
yeah yeah but i don't eat dogs
because because you're not broke
you're [ __ ] ready to eat meals but
also way nicer like i'd actually eat
them but they're actually pretty decent
yeah well what any meals do we have like
when you go sainsbury's you can get
those curries that are like pretty
[ __ ] good they're like two pounds and
they're like really nice like freshly
made card's having a hard time agreeing
yeah but he's tired so his parents made
the curry that's true that's true we
love curry but like how do you you know
i don't know how to make curry you're
like good curry sorry buy the one that's
ready to go and it's like really good
stuff like that like a lot of the ready
to go food is pretty good this video is
sponsored by manscape
taking control of your bush is important
and these products are so good you're
going to be showing your pride in the
new bush free yard save big and be the
most hygienic version of yourself by
using our discount code trash taste for
20 off and free shipping at manscape.com
guys we've been on the road recently and
you know we didn't have our manscaped
box with us so i actually attempted to
cut my balls without using manscape and
i legitimately just cut myself not i'm
not even joking well gun it sounds like
that you needed to get your hands on the
manscape performance package
inside the package is the lawnmower 4.0
this electric trimmer is a bush's worst
nightmare and the second best tool in
the performance package is the weed
whacker with the performance package
purchase you get two free gifts the shed
travel bag and the patented high
performance reduce chafing manscape
boxes so get 20 off plus free shipping
with our code trash taste at
manscape.com i mean come on guys just
look at all of these products they have
you can get all of them back to the
episode if you guys want to go get thai
food here roon pear oh yeah i'm
delicious my friend uh
he's also he was over for a while dude
he would make like he would he was just
making us food because we gave him a
free house yeah yeah yeah so [ __ ]
good
i'm like because i'm like so judgmental
when it comes to thai food because like
my mom was like run around like a thai
restaurant so i'm like
it's kind of like gordon ramsay you know
where where i'm just like you know the
peak yeah
this is the kind of place that didn't
take like i didn't know what a credit
card was until like a year ago okay
that's that's good that's just how
that's up because like when i go to a
thai place and it looks [ __ ] bougie
as [ __ ] i'm like this
now this place has everything it's got
the dying fish in the aquarium in the
front it's got the pass to take cash the
money laundering in the back it's good
it's really good it's called the rune
parrots and like right over the hills
as well like if it doesn't make me a
little uncomfortable to be then it will
not be good yeah yeah yeah the same one
in japan like i don't know how they got
the vibe down like we we found this
really good indian restaurant and it is
literally just like copy and paste the
exact same thing you'd get here where
you walk in it's like unapologetically
like kind of like epic really bad decor
yeah the menu is like it like the
pictures they took looked like a crime
scene yeah it's like they threw the food
on the table and they're like look at
the picture yeah
like what the [ __ ] is this
but then you're like you're like okay
you're trying you're like this is the
best [ __ ] thing yeah i've ever had
it's so good
same thing with like chinese restaurants
right if you go to a chinese restaurant
and there's not some some person with
like like an earpiece like shouting out
orders in chinese when you when you
order in the background you feel
uncomfortable yeah like you're like
what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah
and then they always have to shout back
from the kitchen yeah yeah yeah you know
it's like this is gonna be sick just
aggression yeah it's very aggressive
yeah anger yeah it's like the authentic
japanese like if you go like abroad
right what's
what what's like the fact is what's
what's the factors you think that
well if it's run by a bunch of white
people that's probably not going to be
good
yeah well i mean that's that's true it's
like the first thing i think of the
first thing i see or try to find i'm
like is there a single japanese person
working in this place yeah like in the
kitchen is there is there at least a
japanese girl in the kitchen if yes i
have my hopes up well a lot of the
japanese restaurants are in america and
the uk are often run by chinese people
yeah yeah because they're just like oh
well you guys don't know the difference
yeah exactly exactly and honestly they
don't know the difference a lot of the
times yeah we went to a a place
yesterday and now i don't trust google
reviews in this in the city you can't
yeah it was like 4.5 and it was an
italian 4.5 means garbage
okay okay
what the [ __ ] what 4x5 means every
mcdonald's is 4.5 oh because in japan if
if it's 4.5 it's like it must have like
served god yeah yeah yeah everything is
below like four yeah you're looking for
a four seven four eight yeah oh my [ __ ]
yeah
yeah in japan everything's like 3.5
average and that's still a really good
[ __ ] meal toxicity place that's like
a crime people people in japan like they
complain at anything yeah yeah on the
review not in person yeah yeah
confrontation i'd rather yeah like my
water arrived two seconds late two stars
it is really you should when you go have
a quick read of the google reviews it's
really bizarre seeing what they nitpick
it's really dandy yeah really really odd
like they'll be like they didn't hand me
the menu fast enough
it's really weird so we went to this
italian place and i knew it was like oh
oh we walked in and it was all uh like
there was not a white person in the
restaurant and i was like okay i mean
i'm not saying you can't do it but
you're like
i'm sure there's no shortage of italians
in america america i was like oh no oh
no that uh he ordered lasagna and it was
cold
i got microwave lasagna unfortunately i
took a bite of it i didn't know you
could make a lasagna with zero flavor
yeah yeah like i actually couldn't taste
it yeah it's just like there was like a
baseball game going on there was no news
yeah those are the words just like it's
little americans
what are you who are you appealing to
here like the guy who comes after work
and is like i love italian food
i want a microwave lasagna yeah man but
it's weird because uh la especially has
like a really really good [ __ ] food
scene because it's really competitive
over here yeah they got oh it's the one
saving grace of this [ __ ] of the
city it's so good like if i'm like oh i
want korean food i live in korea town if
i want uh like tacos i just go down the
street and there's a taco truck every 10
feet yeah yeah it's nice it's really
good i love i love mexican food it's so
[ __ ] up
street vendor they're probably good yeah
they might give you food for something
they give me food poisoning i still eat
them
it's just that i still come back that's
just the spice that comes with it you
know
because like yeah when i come to la
every time there's two things i look
forward to it's like mexican food and
korean barbecue i [ __ ] [ __ ] love
korean barbecue so much yeah have you
ever been to korea i've not no no i
actually like i've been to korea once
and i don't know i'm not going to speak
for every korean barbecue but like i
preferred my because i went to korean
barbecue almost every day in korea yeah
and i actually preferred the korean
barbecue i found in l.a i have heard
that that's like it's very similar if
not
like better yeah
because
la or just america is all about
indulgence right so you can really
indulge yourself with like the meats
here yeah and it just feels [ __ ] good
man you like you go to a korean bbq in
l.a you're you're guaranteed to get a
food coma afterwards yeah yeah and
that's like that's that's that's the
feeling i want from a korean barbecue
yeah and i think like the meat quality
here is really good like especially the
beef and everything like that so
yeah like i'm not like
a lot of asian countries import their uh
beef and stuff from other countries yes
oh yeah so like i know japan often japan
gets most of their beef from america
yeah yeah yeah well like japan has like
wagyu beef and everything but i feel
like after living
yeah
that's also like sometimes i don't even
count that as beef it's so fatty it's so
buttery that it just sometimes i've had
wagyu where it's like overwhelmingly
buttery to the point where it's gross
again yeah yeah because like living in
japan wagyu is so easy to get your hands
on that's gonna be every day i mean they
said yes
they sell it in supermarkets yeah and
then you have it once and you're like
this is [ __ ] amazing and then the
tenth time you have it you just really
really that's really rich it's a really
really one bite and you're like oh i
just kind of want like immediately
i actually prefer normal steaks over
wagyu now after like living it makes
sense yeah yeah you have it too much
it's it's kind of [ __ ] yeah it's
really nice like for a one time thing
which is like which is like the
experience here you you yeah exactly you
have one wagyu you have one bite and
it's that [ __ ] amazing bite yeah but
you can buy like steaks of wagyu in
japan and that's like that's like too
much
yeah that's too much don't let the cow
come for two
[Applause]
we went to like a supermarket here in
l.a yesterday and they were selling raw
milk oh yeah do you know about the
supermarket i don't know there's a
supermarket called heroin it sounds like
oh that's the like rich white yeah my
friend told me about it and we just
randomly found it yesterday yeah so i
went in
they were selling
a gallon of milk yeah
called raw milk yeah for twenty dollars
and that milk is is is not treated for
any bacteria that's what makes it raw
yeah so it's just unpasteurized milk
just unpasteurized milk yeah yeah that's
so you're basically just like paying
more for a more dangerous product yeah i
think people are just so obsessed with
like natural here like that to the point
of like dangerous because that's a whole
thing of like fresh water yeah it's yeah
it's like yeah unfortunately you have to
get water that has not been like touched
by anyone right
why do i have to do that
yeah i got like hydrogen infused water
it didn't even come in a bottle it came
in like a bag a bag like an astronaut
bag that doesn't make any sense
it's just water it's still water
because you can't add an atom
i don't even know what it meant you know
it's it's really bizarre seeing the
whole because i feel like this wasn't
here when i came here like 2018 19. the
whole like alkaline water trend there's
a lot of that yeah it's like why is this
a thing they just like to [ __ ] with the
ph and it makes a whole new product it's
like we i think humans have existed
pretty good with this water thing for
like yeah we've been doing it for a long
time like other stuff that i can
i feel like there's other technological
advancements we could be focusing on but
they're like i added some [ __ ] acid
in my water yeah yeah and now i'm like
[ __ ] plain of existence like floating
like it's like what do you expect like i
don't this is such a bizarre thing i do
i don't know and it feels weird how like
it's like do you think i'm dumb enough
to buy this and apparently it's like yes
oh actually yeah in fact our entire
business isn't built around your
stupidity yeah yeah like your thing
didn't even [ __ ] taste good yeah
your thing tasted like like sparkling
water that had like it's flat water like
you know how like flat soda tastes it
tastes disgusting i never have tasted
flat sparkling water before that's
exactly what it tasted like but it's
like it feels like a system-wide
distrust in just how stuff is made here
yeah which is reasonable there's a lot
of bad stuff here there's a lot of like
bad poorly produced food oh yeah gotcha
yeah yeah that's probably where it stems
from yeah like a scary health conscious
thing yeah yeah would you say is the
best american food then
i mean american food has got like a
bunch of other countries kind of stolen
yeah yeah yeah oh you're [ __ ] mocking
yeah you just stole like every other
country i still got it here it's the
thing is still i can go to korean
barbecue we can do that in the uk you
just pay a lot of money yeah and it
takes worse probably
they just you know the uk is just
catching on they're like they're coming
that's like holy [ __ ] we could put
spices for our food
we've been trading this [ __ ] for
hundreds of years and we never thought
to put it in the food whoa
america's like bro what if we put sugar
in this
like um this is salt like you have to
add sugar
to it they should add more sugar add
sugar add oil
as much as the last guy dude [ __ ]
sukiyaki is amazing he's the same idea
right i do like sukiyaki i i prefer
chinese hot pot though i think i think
chinese hot pot [ __ ] should go to um
uh [ __ ] uh
oh
tofu was good though yeah he's made he's
made me eat a lot of questionable [ __ ]
yeah maybe like duck brains yeah that
was interesting it all tastes good
though but joey's you're the guy who
eats everything though right yeah was
there anything that didn't fit your
taste palette no it was all good it was
all good i had like pigs intestines i
had duck sprains it was all it all
slapped
there's very few things that make me not
want to eat it yeah like i had the mud
fish as well the thai mud fish oh that
one's kind of good it's like it's pretty
isn't it the catfish
no no
it's like it's like it's like it's like
salted and fermented mud oh no it's like
it's like fermented it kind of tastes
like if you got a piece of like uh if
you got a sardine and you kind of
put it in the dirt yeah and they just
left it there for a day and you came
back the next day you picked it up and
you ate it oh that's kind of what it
tastes like these [ __ ] just want to
keep fermenting everything it's just too
much fermenting going
just stop fermenting
i just want this to be [ __ ] 20 times
smelly
like just eat the fish
you know what it doesn't smell enough
like puke you know
i really want to really want to feel
like throwing up
most of the fish in japan even i don't i
don't question it i'm like don't tell me
what this is because if you tell me what
you did to this fish
but you eat it and you're like that's
pretty good and then like by the way uh
yeah we we just left this in piss for
five minutes
that's the dish you're like all right
okay
i wonder what the tangy taste was yeah
yeah i've i had funazuchi once which is
like where they take a piece of uh white
fish or something and they ferment it
for 10 years
oh i think i saw that on like an idiot
abroad or something yeah yeah
for her video and i was like i'll try it
because apparently like one of the
reviews was like when you eat it it
feels like you're being electrocuted in
your mouth and i'm like is that a good
thing
it's not even like food at that point oh
yeah yeah yeah eating matter
it's a branding thing to like look what
we have guys because every every place
in japan has to be famous for something
yeah it's really like important for some
reason like whenever you talk to anyone
you're like i went to this place like
did you try the x famous thing in there
yeah yeah and most of the time it's like
it's like no different they're like yeah
their rice is the best amelia always
does this as well every prefecture says
that they have the best rice but
everyone knows it all tastes the same
yeah and almost every prefecture has
like yes mainly i did just say we just
called you out every prefecture has a
specialty fruit as well it seems like
yeah and it's like sometimes it just
tastes good sometimes it tastes good but
like fruit in japan just tastes good in
general i think yeah
yeah yeah hokkaido is like where the
best food is at the big island at the
top yeah yeah [ __ ] amazing yeah yeah
they've somehow perfected food i don't
know how they did it
do you like it when they like kill the
thing in front of you is that like i
think it's probably yeah i love that
yeah
i i didn't want to assume that was your
energy but
that's definitely
like if they kill it in front of me it's
going to just be amazing
yeah yeah there's places where they'll
do that with the crab where they bring
it out oh okay that's what this
yeah that's good i don't even want to
eat it i just wanted to see you guys
that much
these giant [ __ ] crabs the spider
crabs are [ __ ] massive
and you know i was at this place and you
order a crab whatever and i didn't
expect it but they like this this tiny
woman brings out on on like just a
normal serving tray brings out this
giant crab for you to look at she's like
is this okay it's like what what would i
have said like
i would like one that is not this one
bigger yeah you're bigger
bring out a bigger one
did it not have to like fall down
no no no
it's too big to fit through a door yeah
they fold in like the legs and they
bring and it's just it's like trying to
wiggle and you're like oh yeah that one
that one that one's good
when they bring out like the wine for
you to try so you just like swirl it and
you're like
no
i've never seen someone say no this wine
is not good enough
especially when you're like british
you're like this is too awkward i can't
say no yeah i can't be like no also
they've uncorked the wine right so yeah
i feel i feel too bad yeah i've i've
been to a dinner with someone like that
in my head i'm just like you dig it
so what happens when you say no they
bring you enough they just bring you out
and you bring out another one oh you
could just sell of the same wine or no
different different like different that
they think would match better to your
taste buds and i'm just like dude
like you [ __ ] know the difference
yeah you're you're kind of just trying
to be like yeah i know the difference
between these words give me another one
you don't you just want to be a [ __ ]
yeah
you'd never use for the beer you're like
oh that's that way you like that beer
no
[ __ ] off yeah
but like with beer you can just like you
can just pour a little bit you know but
if you uncork a wine it ruins an entire
bottle of wine yeah exactly you know
they can't serve that someone else no
yeah
have you ever been to like an ice cream
place and you just have like that one
guy who just tries every [ __ ] flavor
yeah there's a lemon i think it's four
is it four
three
i think they would let you try
everything yeah that's nice well i mean
a limit culturally i think they'll try
to let you trust but like i feel bad
after yeah
yeah i i mean is is the vanilla really
going to taste that
like i don't understand like yeah okay
sometimes they have some really obscure
flavors you're like okay i do want to
try that but like people like can i try
the uh the chocolate ice cream it's like
yeah yeah you know what chocolate tastes
like you've never had chocolate before
like
it can't taste that different yeah i
refuse to believe this chocolate can
taste so different to the point where
you have to taste it and be that guy who
makes the line weight like yeah come on
yeah again they just want to be the
[ __ ] that's all it is i don't know
i don't i feel bad at costco asking for
the samples
i don't even do that yeah i didn't know
you could do that what
that's the whole point oh oh you mean
the side samples yeah oh no i never go
to those when in japan the costco they
don't really have that many samples yeah
yeah and uh i took uh dynasty emily to
the costco and they were like where's
the samples and i was like uh i mean
there's some and he was like i just ate
i just had four shots of red bull i'm
like why
it was free it's a sample it's a sample
it's free i'm like you know what red
bull tastes like you don't need a sample
of right i always feel bad i never go
for the samples because i always feel
bad because 99 times out of 100 it's
something that i know i don't need yeah
so it's like it's it's taking the sample
and you just like pretending to be like
yeah this is very nice and then just
their eyesight of like you're gonna buy
it right
and i don't have the heart to be like
no
i don't want to see the disappointment
in their eyes when they're just like oh
okay he's like offended he was like is
grapes the only thing they have to
sample what about like the good food
i don't know maybe it's a good grade
there are two types of costco customers
yeah
what do you want them to do like the
first food they have yeah right the hot
dogs are dollar fifty you don't get that
oh yeah it's so good oh the costco 300
yen is it in japan though yeah 300 yen
they mug you off dude 1.50 damn yeah
with the in this economy dude
well they're like they're like in
america like it has to say a dollar
fifty the rest of what they are [ __ ]
raise the price yeah yeah [ __ ] lucky
but like you can get like whole fishes
like uh like giant salmon cuts and stuff
in japan really fresh fish really fresh
sushi yeah sushi can't [ __ ] talk yeah
it's really good stuff
you should go check it out when you're
there your costco membership works
worldwide really yeah yeah yeah that's
funny as far as yeah it's funny when i
moved to japan i thought and i was
asking like locals where to go i thought
people would like be recommending like
you know really local sports underground
places cool restaurants and literally
nine times out of ten people like yo
you've been to the costco here no you've
been to the costco costco in japan it's
fine no it's either you've been to the
costco or have you been to the ikea
i did we do that here yeah
furniture shopping but for the food yeah
yeah food sounds like you i don't like
the food at ikea
do you like the food i like you yeah
meatball's breaking okay it's a [ __ ]
meatball like how i mean you can't
really [ __ ] up a meatball you're
shopping it's an experience but you
can't shop andy it's an experience yeah
i love how the we noticed yesterday uh
we were
pushing the card around i was going to
say trolley yeah yeah it's like glad you
caught yourself yeah i [ __ ] you oh
yeah
dude uh it had a cup holder
i can't put my drink down for like 10
minutes like i got to make sure i'm
[ __ ]
sipping on my big gulp
what if i have a [ __ ] soda that i
don't need i'm drinking man i don't want
to leave that in the car
everyone always has a starbucks at all
times i've noticed oh yeah starbucks is
real big you ever look up a map of
starbucks this year it's crazy it's just
always drinking starbucks yeah yeah i
can't put it down yeah i gotta i gotta i
gotta go to the store pick up my
groceries while drinking a starbucks
yeah sometimes they have starbucks in
the grocery stores they they had that
yeah yeah yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
yeah quite good i mean yeah i'm not
really a big fan of that's they're uh i
like that they have food though
it's like a decent you should check it
out in japan yeah it's it's i think
starbucks is [ __ ] everywhere else i'll
be going a lot of places in japan yeah
yeah the starbucks in japan it's like an
amusement park is it good though because
i think in japan yeah yeah it's [ __ ]
good i think i feel like i i think it's
good but i also part of me is just like
is it just because most other coffee
places in japan suck yeah you know
there's that but i think just like by
itself it's a good coffee yeah don't go
to don't go to doterra that's like don't
think so don't go to any coffee place
that's not something yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah yours
do you know abroad in japan yeah yeah so
one time we were at this place and he
was like uh chris was like
tell us about tallies he was like i'm
telling you they have the best of beef
stroganoff i've ever
i was like
i was like really yeah and we both
ordered it and we were eating it you
know when you you're like telling your
friend like dude this is amazing and
then and then you eat it again and
you're like
that crippling embarrassment of like
yeah it's like when you say this such a
funny youtube video yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's just have never cause he's such a
he'll he's so reluctant to admit he's
wrong yeah yeah yeah so he was like
it's not as
i'm not as good as the last time i was
like he was like could we go eat
something else different televisions
at least he didn't do the thing where
it's like well it's because we're in
this tully like the other tallies i
think he he was like knew i was not
gonna i was gonna be like [ __ ] off
absolutely not this is a chain there's
no [ __ ] way this isn't standardized
these taste like [ __ ] because they're so
skimpy with beef sometimes and beef
dishes make sense yeah yeah because they
don't have as much like three pieces of
beef it was it was it was barely a
stroganoff it was a sauce with
convenience store meal like okay when i
was in japan the first time or i only
went to convenience stores and the
chicken was the best [ __ ] thing it
was the best convenience store chicken i
ever had
are just the best for everything what
what do they have other than chicken and
two other fried items
uh i highly recommend uh the beef bowl
there i i [ __ ] love the beef bowls in
any of the places oh yeah a lot of the
dishes you can just take to them ask
them they'll be like they'll ask you
something just say hi yeah yeah and then
they'll warm it up yeah so they're
warming up on the spot so you can eat it
like i know it's a little controversial
i think
uh 7-eleven hawaii is better than seven
one in japan
really i don't know about that but i
just assume that's a big you should go
next time i put seven eleven in like
singapore is crazy too yeah sure seven
live in singapore's lit yeah i think
like honestly it's it's because the
japanese convenience store standards are
so high but 7-eleven in thailand [ __ ]
slaps yeah like oh yeah honestly
7-eleven just slaps worldwide yeah yeah
you get accepted
yeah holy [ __ ] here yeah
yeah we got lucky with like the asian
influence for the convenience stores
dude it's so good you got like so much
local food like spammers and bees and
like non-stop beef bowls and yeah but
like but when i went to hawaii like
because i was on oahu yeah and i went
into a mall yeah and like 50 of the
stores are just run by japanese people
oh yeah
like i think it's the most japanese yeah
like i went into the mall they had like
billboard ads in japanese yeah like not
even in english and i'm like i thought i
was in a mall in tokyo somewhere yeah
and you can just like pay [ __ ] in yen
and i'm like what yeah you can you can
go into some stores and maybe it was
just that department i don't know but
like i went into this department store
and like fifty percent of the stores you
can go into that are owned by japanese
people you can pay in yen
probably yeah i don't know yeah yeah
it's a it's i think that's the highest
demographic on oahu yeah yeah that's
crazy just like i was walking around
oafu and it's just like every second
person was speaking japanese yeah yeah
that's yeah yeah i like this lady bumped
into me this like old white lady and she
like without even looking she said that
sumo
i was like
i'm from here
i always go for the sandwiches yeah yeah
the sandwiches are really [ __ ] good
yeah tuna and mayo ones from uh
tuna and egg ones and lawson's one of my
favorites okay mini stop they have ice
cream they're they're famous for soft
serve yeah that's really good
so yeah but but i'm trying not to gain
weight right so yeah live in japan it's
a different beast yeah it's like you
can't you can't eat there like you're on
vacation yeah right right and like the
food that you need to be responsible
about it right right and and the food is
healthy for you but the
actual like japan food laws are actually
really lacks like you can put whatever
the [ __ ] you want in a lot of this food
and they have a lot of adjectives and
stuff and uh adjectives [ __ ]
additives
there's a lot of additives in a lot of
food a lot of stuff that's banned
elsewhere in japanese food fun um yep so
it is um there are a lot of stuff that
is super unhealthy for you so you do
have to be careful yeah being like it
being easy to lose weight in japan is
like a misnomer because one food is
amazing there so you're just gonna wanna
eat like i'm gonna eat a [ __ ] ton of it
yeah yeah yeah the portion sizes may be
small but then you end up having six
meals a day yeah it's just like
it doesn't matter yeah everything's oh
i'm gonna be surrounded by fish it's
very easy to avoid fish yeah you don't
want to eat fish it's super easy yeah
yeah thank god so uh yeah whatever you
whatever you like there's more
i feel there's more meat based places
than fish-based places oh god yeah yeah
but also there's more fish-based places
than pretty much everywhere else in the
world yeah of course it's just a lot of
food that's why being vegetarian and
vegan in japan is like so [ __ ] hard
yeah oh vegan
i mean it's getting better like there's
a lot more vegan places in tokyo now but
i remember like five years ago there was
like two yeah i've never seen a
gluten-free option that's just never
been happening either
like yeah they're like you're gluten
free for the cycle yeah
like
you know
we're not like going for natural
selection here you know
you want the cream of the grass
lactose intolerant just tolerated yeah
just tolerate it just shoot yourself and
you'll be right
[ __ ] i'm so hungry now yes i'm [ __ ]
hungry now
he's been starving getting some food
after this
yeah let's go conbini off this already
let's go let me show you the seven
lemons here you get hot dogs
everything looks in the 7-eleven here
like it's going to kill you yeah the hot
dog has been on like the little roller
conveyor belt for hours does anyone
actually eat that no i like i mean not
like
it's not like the same where it's like
let's go to the convenience store it's
like i'm in my time of need
i need to eat food within 50 feet or
i'll pass away and it's 7 11. what about
like those hot dog stalls because i
always see them outside ax and like the
guys there's people on the street
oh yeah and they look dirty as [ __ ] no i
smell really good i had one one year
because i was like i'm starving i don't
want to walk all the way to a restaurant
it's just there it smells amazing i had
it i immediately felt sick
like not even it's like it's like not
like i was i was not having a
refrigeration yeah i was not even
halfway through this hot dog and i was
like i think i'm about to throw off
let's go
[ __ ] god bless america god bless
america god bless america that's [ __ ]
freedom right there yeah we saw a
budweiser case on the side of it she
said freedom and i was like
yes [ __ ] yeah big american flag it's
just like
yeah yeah seeing how patriotic people
are it doesn't exist in the uk it's just
like miserable yeah that's kind of fun
it's great it's just like coming here it
like you see it on tv and it doesn't
feel real and then you actually see how
patriotic people are you're like holy
yeah
that's hilarious yeah that's so good
so [ __ ] funny imagine loving your
country right
that's just what
what
i don't know it's crazy but anyway like
is there anything big you're working on
now or anything you want to shout out
yeah i got a video coming going come and
go whenever you feel like it's from now
that's hopefully um
it's going to be tough i'm going to go
to japan philippines then hawaii oh so
you're going to do no work i'm going to
do no work [ __ ] yeah so that sucks um
yeah i have a cousin's wedding in hawaii
we're going to convention in the
philippines
japan yeah sick um so yeah that'll be a
minute
we should we should think about doing
that we just [ __ ] work wherever we go
now yeah
imagine taking a vacation which came
with us imagine not taking your entire
office with you everywhere you go like
whoa having the airline
that one
go to our patreon patreon.com also
follow us on twitter send us some memes
on the subreddit and if you hate our
face listen to us on spotify and uh go
check out michael's stuff links in the
description
all right yeah thanks for coming thanks
for coming on man thank you for having
me bye
god bless america
[ __ ] bless america
[Music]
you